there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's wednesday yep time
once again for our live stream show yep
gonna do navajo code talkers which
that's with one that won the poll on the
uh
patreon
yeah i think somebody recommended it a
couple weeks ago i don't remember what
the topic of the show was but somebody
recommended i said oh yeah that's a
really good idea i called the show like
native american code talkers because
even though like the navajo ones are
like the best known um they actually did
have some other tribes that also
uh that also participated in it and used
their native languages as well but it
wasn't quite as widespread i think or as
well known but i kind of wanted to
you know branch out and like mention
that as well even though like i said the
navajo code talker is probably the best
known one
looks like people start to show up tammy
just uh jumped into the comment section
we'll be starting the show here in a
minute hey everybody what's going on
yeah so it is a wednesday yes it is
and um
i took the bike and went down to the uh
um
down to the printers and got all the
designs for the new shirts they look
good
um
i got a
a canon films
i got an ocp omni consumer products from
like from robocop got one of those
got um
uh was it corker how do you say it
corcodia corralco coco
correlco was correlco studios got one of
those
uh what else did we have mega man an
omega man the omega man looks really
good it's just the font from the movie
looks real good um
kind of that demonic looking font
and um
i got each one of them i got this i got
a small one and i got a [ __ ] big size
one for different kinds of shirts
so if you guys gonna want if you guys
want a big shirt i got i got stuff for
big like extra extra large got stuff for
that
or you know
i like i like the smaller ones on
mediums and [ __ ] smalls and even even
large actually i think the the medium
size or the the smaller logo looks
better on them that just depends on
whatever you want so i'm going to get
some of those framed up
in next couple days
and uh i'll get a uh
some mediums [ __ ] shot i'll wear them
on the show [ __ ] promo
and i know there's already i know
there's already a couple people that
want to
want uh the ocp ones i'm gonna send some
to uh
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] drawing a blank plank
on his name not drunk yet yeah i was
gonna say you're not even drunk
although you probably had some beers at
the bar right but that was a while no
yeah it was murder hornets
for him oh that's another thing too is
that uh the movie retrospective this
week i had to do it by myself because
you were uh at the bar and you didn't
come
back you'd be all right
so i was like i didn't know what you
told me because i thought you were only
there for an hour i thought you were
just going to the print shop and then
kind of come right back and we could
record the yeah the review but then you
said you were at the bar and i was like
well [ __ ] maybe he's probably going to
be gone all afternoon i was only going
there for an hour so well i didn't know
that so i just like recorded it myself
okay because it had to be edited and
gone up so the movie respective is just
me that's good um but you know tom
watched the movie too but he didn't like
it i didn't like it either but you know
oh yeah
yeah i wouldn't have anything to say
about that
it would have been funny like freaking
me on it but because it because it was
bad but i'm sure you covered it
that was i did like some [ __ ] straight
up that was like a bad episode of star
trek it was i think it looked just like
star trek
did you find out where that studio was
was
i did not i'm pretty sure and i think i
said that on the thing i was like i
thought the movie was shot in the
philippines okay so i'm guessing i mean
obviously the exteriors were but the
interiors i have no idea where that is
it definitely looked like some like star
trek some love motel over in the
philippines or you know or playing in
the apes or something it looked like
that
uh tammy said i might be in and out of
the chat tonight puppy stepped on a bee
just a few minutes ago oh no yeah
well hopefully the puppy's gonna be okay
oh my goodness stepping on a v
camp guys got it messed up because i bet
those nazis were stumped when they first
heard the code talking that was the
japanese they were fighting the japanese
we weren't fighting the germans
uh well they may have sent some i don't
think so though
i i remember the weird thing about it is
that um well the germans actually
because i want to get into that a little
bit too i know like the navajo code
talkers that's mainly a world war ii
thing but they did
uh they did kind of utilize it a little
bit in world war one
and the germans actually knew about that
so we'll kind of get into that uh from
world war one okay so we'll get into
that but the interesting thing about it
i was watching this documentary
about it and apparently during some of
the battles where the navajo code
talkers were employed
uh some of the people like at the place
where they were going like didn't know
that they had navajo code talkers so
it's like so they thought it was
japanese because they're like what the
[ __ ] did the japanese like infiltrate
like our radio signals because nobody
told them
that they had like this that they had
the code talkers there so yeah it was
just like a lack of communication like
all that on the part because i mean
there weren't
i think at max there were what like 300
of them i think like during world war ii
i believe that's navajo there were some
other ones too but like i said it's the
whole procedure like it wasn't
it didn't start in world war ii they had
some in world war one it just wasn't as
widespread but the germans knew about it
from world war one that's why they tried
to like circumvent it but the the ones
that were the ones that got famous were
mostly marine corps
code talkers and they were fighting in
the pacific against the japanese
and they had some uh
hardcore orders um they they fully
understood
um a code talker fully understood that
he could not be captured
so you couldn't let a code talker fall
into enemy hands
so that meant
if you had to you had to kill a code
talker you couldn't let the enemy have
them
yeah i mean that was
well they were too important they agreed
to that they did actually like um i saw
uh i think all of the sadly all of the
original code talkers i think are dead i
think like the last one died in 2020 or
2021
um but one of them said yeah we had this
thing it's like it didn't come out until
later yeah but they always were in pairs
and they said yeah if we both got
captured like you were supposed to like
shoot just that you're supposed to shoot
each other yeah um which you can do it
those guys that [ __ ] columbine did it
you just count down
that way you don't have to pull the
trigger on yourself it's a lot
psychologically because really that's
the only way
that the code would have been broken is
if they had captured and tortured
one of the code talkers and got them
there was absolutely no other way to
break it right so and they never did
that it's the only the language is too
irregular and it was uh had too much
[ __ ] slang in it and it was tribal
slang and a lot of it they knew how to
hint to each other using that language
so they didn't actually kind of have to
say what they were talking about it
wasn't that that's not that's not uh why
it worked
okay well that's what i was told yeah
that's not why it worked it was hard to
crack and they were also from understand
that they and sometimes that the indians
knew each other so they could do stuff
over the over the uh
over the radio that only two indians
that actually knew each other could get
away with with doing
that that's what i was that's what i
remember hearing yeah that's well the
reason it works well there were several
reasons we're gonna already get into the
show what you know i'm just saying well
well because you were talking about it
um there were several reasons one of the
reasons being probably the the most
important reason being that um
one like hardly anybody spoke it other
than navajo and maybe less than 30
white people like non-navajo people knew
how to speak it so almost nobody yeah um
and
they it wasn't just that because it
wasn't just a case of oh we're going to
just translate an english message into
navajo they also put another layer of
coding on it
um
so that
even if even if a navajo speaker heard
it they wouldn't know what it was if
they weren't one of the code talkers
they still wouldn't know it'd just sound
like gibberish so it wasn't just them
talking in their native language okay
well then what i was told was true
that's basically the same thing
well it didn't have anything to do with
them being friends or anything like that
because they did like train the people
but
they had like this actually if you go on
the um on the marines website or the
navy website they have the dictionary
now because it's all been declassified
obviously and they have like all of the
terms that they had in there and how
they uh how they encoded the alphabet
and how they did all that kind of stuff
so it's actually like really interesting
so we'll kind of so i remember one of
them was saying that they didn't have to
use the code that much they did is for
certain things real important stuff but
on daily stuff they could just use their
normal language and just do use a bunch
of hinting and a bunch of [ __ ] that only
two dudes would know what it was they're
like hey you got the thing yeah the
thing is here
yeah then we'll be there at the place i
mean they only used it like that they
only used it if it was yeah like import
like hey we're going to do like a sneak
attack on xyz and we're or the troop
deployment's going to be here and they
didn't want the enemy picking that up
obviously right so they would use it for
that but they wouldn't use it for just
like everyday [ __ ] obviously but yeah
it's it's again like a really i didn't i
didn't know that much about it but like
the more i researched about it was like
really really cool but i loved like
stuff about codes and [ __ ] anyway so
some of them were platoon level [ __ ]
rtos though yeah from what i remember i
was rto for one of the platoons i was in
for a while and i was also an rto in the
first 327 recon it's a [ __ ] radio
operator gotta carry it on your back
your weapons m16 yeah and it's [ __ ]
in those days is the prc 177 with the
[ __ ] slugger [ __ ] sluggers and
syngars on top of it and [ __ ] not
sluggers what was that thing called
[ __ ]
it was their scrambler we had to put on
there it was a piece of [ __ ]
heavy
um it's only like a [ __ ] one watt
radio those little balfangs are five
watts you can carry those around
but it was just a bulletproof [ __ ]
radio
and i think the world war ii one wasn't
that
wasn't that much more sophisticated than
ours
about to say when i was carrying was
more like vietnam 1980s era
like something out of dumb
aliens
this looks like a big metal box with
handles on it [ __ ] knobs
real primitive
it uh it worked though and it could work
[ __ ] in all conditions you know
freezing cold [ __ ] hot
huge batteries on the bottom of it
um pouring rain you could [ __ ] have
it in your ruck and go through the water
and come out and work
grifter says always amazed at how native
americans were true patriots despite the
history of manifest destiny a true
warrior culture yeah i wanted to get a
little bit into that like not not a huge
amount but i wanted to talk a little bit
about in particular like the navajo and
their kind of uh
contentious dealings with the us
government like after the civil war and
um but the fact that they
not just the fact they're like yes a
warrior culture but they're very like
protective of their own lands and stuff
like that so a lot of them
particularly when the code talker
program came along um they really like
volunteered and some of them like even
lied about their age they said they got
some of them and they were like as young
as 15 years old like lying saying that
because they really wanted
to i mean most of them joined after
pearl after the pearl harbor attack
during the time i was in i don't know
what the statistics are now but when it
came to army in the infantry
um if you were to look at ethnic
demographics
um native americans were highly
overrepresented highly
in other words uh they they had the
highest incident
of uh
volunteer service
going into combat arms and they all
wanted infantry
you know they don't want to be
paratroopers or rangers and because
that's in their culture
it's a macho culture
and
the the greatest part of a young man's
life is to either be a hunter or a
warrior and that and you know this goes
back generations
people don't understand it
if you go back to the 1800s
and you can [ __ ] look this up and
just look at photographs
out in the plains the biggest part of
the u.s cavalry were all
were all lakota
just
lakota upon lakota whole units of them
lakota and american uniforms with like
one white officer every now and then
just more and more lakota code and it's
because when
when the when the union started to
expand into their territory
technology came before the union did so
lifestyles were changing because there
were trains and people started owning
land and putting up them
fences and they had cattle
so technology expanded faster than the
united states did so the world had
already kind of changed and indians or
native americans were
adopted technology as it came you know
they weren't anti-technological
matter of fact most of the time they had
money and they had
the best equipment they could afford and
a lot of times it was better than what
the us army had
when they fought the us army they were
using lever action repeaters in a time
when the us army was using a single shot
falling block rifles which are a lot
slower
so the army didn't really get the good
[ __ ] civilians had the good [ __ ] and
then the indians were civilians
well
as the union started to expand their
territory a lot of the [ __ ] a lot of
their lifestyle was already gone
and they were kind of given the deal
that kind of with xerxes out of [ __ ]
300 you know you join my ranks and i
would you will carry your banner far
through europa you know that kind of
[ __ ] you know so joining the u.s army
was just
another way of
becoming well equipped and well
organized and trained to defend their
own territory because they worked in
their own territory yeah so they just
became
they were u.s army but they were
defending their own territory in that
uniform
in that legal structure
and
they were also all the cops if you go to
southwest
new mexico utah
you know
texas
all these places
there have been
native american law enforcement and
soldiers they're going back centuries
centuries this isn't new it's just that
these [ __ ] educational galaxy brains
up in boston and [ __ ] had no idea of of
the culture down here they don't know
they're they're looking at it through
the prisms of
of
their
ideologies
here's an example one [ __ ] sergeant
zamora
was my squad leader when i was in korea
over at uh at camp greaves up near the
dmz
his dad was lonnie zamora
the dude who saw the ufo down in new
mexico that was his dad we still need to
do a show still gotta just still got a
show dude it's written down i put it in
the poll a couple times
yeah that was his name was uh my hit his
son was lonnie zamora jr who was my
squad leader was a big old native
american dude
he was he was twice the size of his dad
his dad is like a little short dude
but uh you know what you'll see you'll
see zamora i think it's lonnie zamora
just look up what was the name that new
mexico ufo yeah or you can just look up
his name because i think i called it the
lonnie zamora ufo yeah because it's
pretty famous like in ufo ufo circles
yeah i was at the guard posters that
guard post collier laying down on the
ground on a [ __ ] sleeping bag on a
[ __ ] rolled out [ __ ] pad which is a
mat we used to sleep on
getting ready for a night shift he's
down here smoking cigarettes smoking
with another guy and we would we were
hearing
sergeant zemora tell that story
and he's telling the story like his dad
was famous
and i had never heard of it before then
later i found out that damn that is a
famous case
and there were some details that his dad
couldn't let out
but
sergeant zamora
said that his dad didn't think it was
extraterrestrial
he
there was a symbol on it that he saw and
the [ __ ]
intelligence guys there was part of the
fbi says don't talk about that
there was a signal there was a symbol he
drew on it and i think what it was is it
was one of those [ __ ] range finding
things that you could you could put a
telescope on to figure out how far away
it was and how fast it was moving
so which i think was some kind of test
craft i think it was something like a
test craft for some kind of lunar lander
that's what i think it was
something that had a rocket on the
bottom of it it could take off
vertically vertically and land
startup 78 said one of the flag raisers
on iwo jima was native american yeah
that's right yeah ira hayes he was a
marine paratrooper yeah yeah and
honestly um many many uh historians as
well as some like commanders and stuff
like that that were there have said that
it if it wasn't for the navajo code
talkers uh we would not have taken iwo
jima the u.s yeah i've taken it because
they were like so important in relaying
particular information so a lot of them
were there
if you see like interviews with
the ones that were my stupid phones were
inside yeah um was uh
some of the ones that were surviving
like i said they've all passed away now
but the documentary i saw was from a
couple years ago so they were they still
like interviewed like a few of them are
that were still alive at the time and um
several of them they talked to were
there we're uh we're on iwo jima we're
talking about like how [ __ ]
horrifying it was but i mean that's kind
of the thing he was talking uh about
how the japanese had it all because i
think you brought this up before had it
all like undercut with tunnels and stuff
like that it's totally undermining so
the one and he's like and we were kind
of on high ground like shoot him so it's
like they could see us but we couldn't
see them like the one guy said i don't
think i saw a single japanese soldier
like he's like i saw them like shooting
at us and stuff like that but he's like
i never saw one of them because they
were under ground although they shoot
through holes yeah the whole thing was
undermined yeah because there was no
defense they knew about they knew about
um naval bombardment and they knew that
the navy would shove just bombard the
[ __ ] place
they didn't even really resist landing
they said there was a waste of men they
just let us on and they wanted to get us
down in those tunnels
most of those japanese guys died not
from gunfire not even from flamethrowers
they got died because we buried them
buried them buried them alive and the
whole thing about that was i think what
was it 200 000 japanese troops they sent
on there and they basically said um you
just go on there and like wipe everybody
out you told the japanese or don't come
back essentially yeah you couldn't take
them prisoner what were you gonna do
with them right put them on the ship
yeah you had to continue forward you
couldn't put them on the ship so that
was the bad thing about island fighting
is that it's to the death you can't take
prisoners
luckily they didn't surrender though
because you know then you have to kill a
prisoner that had surrendered yeah
because there was no way out neither
side could take prisoners
because the japanese couldn't take your
prisoner what were they going to do with
you
they weren't even getting food they
couldn't get off the island
they were already kind of starving
but uh
no they mostly died
with the
sherman tanks with bulldozer blades on
the front of them and explosive charges
collapsing the fronts of the tunnels
they just buried them
and they never came out
i mean they shot a lot of them up but
yeah i was watching them like i said
some of the some of the documentaries i
saw had like lots of uh footage from
that and it's like man [ __ ] dead
bodies everywhere yeah it's pretty
horrible the worst one was pele that was
the worst one yeah
i was just talking about iwo jima in
particular because that was one where
like the code talkers were peleliu was
the one they all went crazy and were
taking heads and putting heads around
their fighting positions and sticking
heads on the front of [ __ ] tanks and
rot some guys would be fighting
trapped in between
in between [ __ ] snipers positions in
there you know the japanese shooting at
them they'd be behind a pile of rocks
with the three or four rotten japanese
heads
up on there because they couldn't move
out of there and they would just as they
would kill people they'd start
both both sides were just fighting to
the death you
they found what what really kicked that
one off is like on day two or three one
of the us union units found a an
american guy that had been tied to a
stake and had his
dick cut off and [ __ ] tortured to
death and they saw that and that was it
they [ __ ] that that started the
insanity
but it was uh
taking heads that was the that was the
thing for pele though and then once that
[ __ ] was over
they uh pretended like it didn't happen
there was really no reason for pele lou
they could have went around the island
because those guys weren't getting fed
anyway they would have starved out a few
in a few weeks a few months anyway
there was no way they could get off that
island
because you know the japanese navy was
[ __ ]
but the thinking of the time is well
there's the enemy let's go get them
yeah you know can't leave them there you
could have though
but uh yeah they kind of tried to erase
peli luke
i think that was the one that uh
um ed wood was on wouldn't it belly lube
might have been yeah now that you know i
can understand why he'd [ __ ] he was
crazy
he was [ __ ] on pele with wearing
women's underwear that's pretty ballsy
you guys
i have to say
camp guy said i don't know if i would
rather be in the european theater or in
the pacific i think europe would be
easier
probably
i mean from everything i know about the
whole pacific theater world war two that
sounds like a [ __ ] i mean it all
sounds like a nightmare but [ __ ]
no thanks there were two real [ __ ]
savage places in that in that era the
eastern front between the but that was
the germans the germans and the russians
man
they just ground each other down to
nothing real bad
bad [ __ ] happened up there
and civilians were sometimes caught in
the middle of them and [ __ ] starving
to death in cities you know [ __ ]
that's where all that hannibal elector
[ __ ] [ __ ] was happening
that was pretty bad and then the island
fighting the island
some experts said that [ __ ] the
island fighting was probably the most
savage warfare in the history of mankind
might have been
that
on the island fighting between us and
japan and i don't really doubt it
because
a lot of it wasn't recorded
you know what i mean
so much bad [ __ ] happened out there
[ __ ] that would have been considered war
crimes there was no witnesses there's no
civilians there and the army's not gonna
rat on itself
it was just go it was just going out
there annihilating japanese soldiers you
couldn't take them prisoner
they were fighting to the death anyway
both sides you couldn't
you it was just
you're you're on an island there's no
way on or off the japanese couldn't get
on or off their their their navy was
[ __ ] all tied up
and they were kind of starving to death
by the time we were getting there to
them
and uh it was like i said you could have
gone around a lot of those islands but
they're out there in their boat they're
out there in those boats with all those
troops as well let's get them that's
what we're here for
you know what else are we getting yeah
yeah
well they weren't they weren't shy of
men or anything and material we had a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ton of dudes and a [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] ammunition
so they just [ __ ] attacked every
[ __ ] island in sight just leapfrogged
their way up
just systematic
oracle says my grandfather served in the
pacific theater mine did as well uh and
he had nightmares until the end of his
life yeah i believe it
cam guy said my uncle was in europe and
he didn't talk about it much yeah my
grandfather was in the uh pacific
theater as well he died a long time ago
actually he died in
1991 yeah
he didn't really talk about it all that
much either he had like a couple photos
from it that were on the wall but with
him and his buddies but
he didn't really talk about it either so
i don't know what the [ __ ] he saw you
know what i mean the worst place like i
said
you had
the eastern front which was a frozen
hell yeah
a frozen hell of insanity like a damn
slayer video or something okay like a
slayer song
uh you didn't if you went into the if
you went to the eastern front whether
you were russian or german you were
probably you were you were a dead man
your chances were [ __ ] very slim
the pacific war
that island hop and stuff
if you were japanese you were toast
toast
um you had a lot better chance if you
were american but you were still in a
[ __ ]
super humid super hot hell
on these little bitty islands tropical
hell
not good
i think the thing that bothers me the
most about it is that
i mean you're on a teeny little island
like in the middle of a massive [ __ ]
ocean yeah nowhere to go yeah you really
don't have anywhere to go nowhere to go
and it's like if you get stranded there
you're kind of [ __ ]
you know what i mean so it's like no
thank you i'm not really a big fan of
being stranded out in the middle of the
ocean and we [ __ ] up the japanese navy
so those guys weren't being fed they
were [ __ ] starving to death out there
went and trying to fight
and it made sense you know i mean they
were trying to stop us
because they were told that we would
make it to the japanese home island and
rape and murder all their women they
believed it
because that's what they did to the
chinese women down in nanjing yeah i
mean so that's probably not they
probably weren't exaggerating i mean
because that happened before yeah
uh gis would go through the the
knapsacks and the personal possessions
of the dead japanese they'd find
basically snuff photos that they took in
nankang and guys were like what the [ __ ]
is going on
they didn't know where those photos were
from they were just handing them up to
intel
they thought it was japanese doing that
to other japanese people they didn't
know what they were seeing
because you know they did couldn't come
apart
they looked to be the same race
so they were mystified other guys
evidently knew that that was somewhere
in china
but
yeah that [ __ ] uh and a lot of that [ __ ]
didn't come out until like no later no
they didn't know about it at the time
yeah i mean people they know about it
now but they didn't really know about it
at the time it all kind of like
they were like
who are these guys you know but they
never said some kind of gangsters or
something you know they didn't know what
it was thanks yeah
zach says i wonder how many serial
killers there would have been in the 70s
and 80s if those guys hadn't grown up
for with abusive dads from war-related
ptsd i'm sure that probably contributed
you know what i mean i'm sure it's not
the only thing i'm sure
but a lot of them did have
um dads of that generation and a lot of
their dads were
abusive or drunk or neglectful or
something
so not all of them obviously but
you know i'm sure that contributed as
well without that pacific island
fighting there never would have been
suburbia as you know it there never
would have been
television sitcoms as you know them
there wouldn't have been bewitched there
wouldn't have been [ __ ] i dream of
genie uh there wouldn't have been
father's nose best a lot of stuff that
uh you white people would still be urban
uh for the most part
all the [ __ ] things that contemporary
americans believe is to be like the
standards for american life and the
american lifestyle the american dreams
was all product
of a [ __ ]
federal
program to
kind of re-civilize these white guys
coming back from world war ii
because they were scared of them
well because they'd seen pretty much the
worst [ __ ] that you would ever ever and
experience like some of the worst [ __ ]
you'd ever want to see you know what i
mean they had all these dudes that had
survived it and they were like what are
we going to do with these guys we can't
really bring them back
you know what are we going to do with
them well we got to keep them busy we
got to reward them
so the the plan was is to get them
to work in car factories and factories
doing mass production
of household appliances
and then to get them out of cities into
into the suburbs
and make them live civilized lives
with a woman taking care of them
okay and then let them age out
and that was the parents of the baby
boomers you know
so they came back and had a lot of kids
and lived a suburban life and they made
all the hollywood and television get on
board to promote that
that
that [ __ ] that idea that idealized
house picket fence you know and all that
kind you know with the with the dog and
the cat and
they did that through television you
know with fathers knows best and i dream
of genie and
and you know you ever notice i dream of
genie he's these are officers back at
home in a civilized environment and
they're being normal guys and having fun
you know what i mean and hot broads and
[ __ ] like that you know what i mean she
came out of a bottle
that's all to appeal to veterans
you know yeah because like i said they
probably didn't want to see any more of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] when they got back
either well no i think they wanted to
see military guys they could relate to
but they're living
well that's what i mainly like that i
meant that when they got back it's like
they'd seen the worst of the worst and
it's like i just want like a normal life
like a nice life where i don't have to
like see that [ __ ] anymore exactly
exactly you know
which is completely understandable
they had enough of that
and uh they just wanted to kick back and
uh drink
and uh work and uh some steaks
eat some steaks
and uh have a hot wife and pump out a
few kids and then die off that's that's
really what they want they were sick of
it
and i think it worked like i said you
can't blame them it worked that's what
happened to a lot of them
yeah
but the thing about it is that because
they had seen the worst of the worst i
think a lot of times
uh even if they lived like a regular
life and worked a regular job the rest
of their days and had a wife and kids it
leaked out in other ways like i said you
know a lot of them died early or they
had problems with alcohol alcoholics or
you know they beat their kids or some
[ __ ] like that obviously it wasn't all
of them but
it you know it came out in other ways i
think a lot of them were alcoholics yeah
um a lot of them kind of looked down
their noses at people that weren't in a
war
like oh you got it easy you know what i
mean so you know you'll never know well
well the stupid thing is i always
thought that was so dumb because it's
like like dudes they go off and like i
said dudes that were in world war one or
world war ii and they just saw like the
worst [ __ ] ever like nobody should
[ __ ] have to see that
and then they get home and then they're
like okay well i don't want to see that
anymore that sucked it was like
nightmarish and then they get home and
they have kids and their kids have kids
and there's oh you kids today you're so
soft you haven't had i'm like well good
i mean i thought that's what you wanted
you don't want your kids to like have to
go through the same [ __ ] that's not what
would happen though i know but i'm just
saying what was happening is they were
coming back and they would see people
whine and cry over [ __ ] that it's not a
problem you know i mean they were seeing
first world problems
so they were like you guys are [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're crying about that you
know what i mean you got you got it made
and you're crying so
then they would say oh shut up old man
and then they're being disrespected so
like oh [ __ ] you [ __ ]
so you know i mean but then you have
some dudes they're just bad you know
they're gonna take it out on a little
kid
yeah you know what i mean it's um
like a little kid doesn't know it's like
they you know they've never been they've
never [ __ ] no that might have helped
create some of these [ __ ] weird
psychos that came around later but yeah
that's what zach was saying i think
there's absolutely like i said i'm sure
there's lots of factors but i'm sure
that was like a big thing it was a bunch
of different factors one of them lead
poisoning they never want to talk about
that damn leaded gasoline
see
they never want to talk i've heard no
i've heard other people say that those
companies are still around i've heard
other people say that too there's been
no lawsuits because all those people
[ __ ] are i don't think that's like i
said i don't think that's the only
factor
one of them but i definitely think it
was it was and like i said you're not
the only person that said i've seen
other criminologists and stuff like that
like bring that up as well as another
contributing factor yeah
but i mean i think there absolutely is
something to be said for all of the
veterans that came back from more like
kind of all [ __ ] up and you're talking
about a time period in history too
where
it wasn't really accepted
for for example like a dude to go to
like a counselor or something like that
you were seen as like
that was seen as effeminate i guess or
you weren't like dealing with your [ __ ]
like you were supposed to be stoic and
you weren't supposed to talk about your
problems or anything like that you were
supposed to like get on with it so i
kind of feel like a lot of dudes they
maybe had these like horrible
emotions and they didn't really know how
to deal with them like they couldn't
talk to anybody about them and they
couldn't
you know they didn't really know how to
deal with them so they just kind of like
suppress them and then it just kind of
like leaked out in other ways like you
said alcoholism or violence or other
types of things like that glenn's ass
not how come ira had an irish name was
he part white uh indians and irish
crossbred got all the way back to 1500
1600s right yeah all the way back i mean
what was his name quanah parker
was one of them he was part irish and he
was a big indian chief
um he was around so and then um
the the seminoles in this area had a lot
of irish
type members um that was one of the
reasons why
um
andrew jackson he thought this whole
tribal identity stuff was [ __ ] you
were either an american or you were an
indian and if you were going to be an
american you had to be an american
citizen
if you wanted to be an indian you had to
go out to the indian territory you
couldn't have he didn't believe he and a
lot of people agreed with him that you
couldn't have um
you couldn't have dual citizenship
basically is what you're saying you had
to have one citizenship or another said
and and then he then
uh um
he'd come out and say
if you look at a lot of these indian
tribes
they put on white man's clothes and come
into town and uh buy things from the
store and live like anybody else be in
and they're they're white
okay
so they're they're not
they're white when they want to be white
and then they're indian when they want
to when they're indian when it comes
time to pay taxes he was that's that was
one of the things that jackson said
about him
so there were some people that
if you probably did a dna test on them
they'd be fully european but they were
living a tribal lifestyle there was lots
of those
so it's not as
it's not as cut and dried as it is
hollywood lead you to believe and it was
all dependent on what area
some areas
were mixed some areas where
like evidently evidently there were
parts of the the seminoles were just
irish people
you know they had indian relatives but
they were just irish american people
and black people are also seminal
so
the modern modern ideology about racial
identity and tribal groups it doesn't
apply
they were all interbreeding well it's
always much messier as well i messier
than that right and always has been like
yeah from the beginning of humanity yeah
and not all native americans here's
another thing is that [ __ ] the
hollywood notion is that
the indians all got along no
no
well we'll get into that a little bit no
you don't like each other
i mean depending on yeah
yeah it was just like europe the english
and the french and the germans
constantly added each other the indians
were just like that
uh like um
the seminole could not stand the creek
that was one of the reasons why they
didn't want to go to indian territory
because
they were going to put them in they were
going to give them land that was
neighboring the creek indians and they
were like [ __ ] no we hate them people
because they've been at war with them
so
you know they didn't want to go
eventually they did go or some of them
did most of them took american
citizenship there were three seminal
wars here
each one smaller than the last and they
were kind of different but
it worked out i was just reading a book
recently where where he brought up the
uh the long-standing feud between the
blackfeet and the crow yeah how they
couldn't stand each other yeah so
some of them were just mortal enemies
yeah you know
okay see jeffy art says my grandpa made
my dad and his brothers kneel on rice
holding out soup cans if they dropped
their arms they were whipped with the
belt
like what is even the point of that
like what is
i don't know
i don't know
that's the thing see yes
i don't really understand the point of
that like why you would do that to a
little kid but okay
i mean i get where they're coming from
like you know given what they went
through but that's still just like a
little kid listen to what oracle says
read what oracle said
uh what i find interesting is many uh
native americans have a strong tradition
of intellectual property as in hey you
can't perform that dance that's my
family's dance and you are a kid yeah i
get it i get it well the thing about it
too is that which is one of the things
we'll get into when we're talking about
the code talkers is that a lot of their
traditions were um orally passed on
because a lot of their languages were
orally passed on a lot of them didn't
have uh didn't write them down and so
everything was
memory and it was passed down like from
generation to generation so i can see
how they would get like really really
invested in their own stuff like their
own stuff that they were doing in there
like they see some like [ __ ] neighbor
tribe doing it they'd be like hey you
[ __ ] knock that off you're not
allowed to do the [ __ ] yeah the
[ __ ] dance like that yeah that's our
deal yeah
you can go on youtube and just look up
tribal dances
and they have whole events where they go
and they put on their traditional attire
and then they go out there and do their
dances and
making music and [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
know it it's cool they still do it get
together and have a big family i think
they actually call them powwows they do
yeah yeah they call them powwows yeah i
went to a couple when i returned yeah i
went to a couple when i was a kid yeah
but um
you know a long time ago somewhere in
florida i guess it was probably around
here someplace daytona or deland or
yeah ocala or some [ __ ] like that i
don't really remember where it was but
it was around here somewhere it's fun
though
um all right so how long have we been
talking okay so we've talked about 45
minutes you want to like get into the
[ __ ] yeah quick all right
so a little bit before we get into the
like code talker stuff i kind of want to
get a little bit into like i said some
of the other tribes uh participate in
this too but you know i want to talk a
little bit about the navajo because
they're kind of like the best known ones
so i wanted to get a tiny bit into
sort of like their history of their
conflicts like with the us government
particularly
um and in particular there's one thing
which was called the long walk which
we'll get into in a little bit
but i kind of feel like well there was
kind of like i don't want to call it an
uneasy piece but there wasn't really
like open hostilities until about 1849
um
when the uh you know the european
americans that were kind of like you
know in the country then
uh actually scalped one of their uh
navajo leaders whose name was narbona
and that was in 1849. so after that they
got a little bit mad about it as he
would
and then like hostility started to
escalate now there were i believe three
um kind of uh truces or treaties or
whatever that they try to go like over
the next couple years
and in those treaties they would always
say oh well the us army is supposed to
protect the navajo
but they never did it never really
worked out that way uh the army would
basically allow uh other native american
tribes specifically the utes and also
mexicans
to essentially um steal from the navajo
like take their livestock and stuff like
that and capture them and use them as
slaves and the army wouldn't do anything
about it
so there was that uh they had also set
up some government schools like the
bureau of indian affairs they had set up
some schools there to
ostensibly like educate the navajo
children but what they were really doing
was
trying to
make them not be navajo like they were
allowed to speak their native language
they would get punished um they weren't
allowed to like wear traditional dress
or like talk about their culture or
anything like that i'm trying to get
them to
join the uh america yeah they're trying
to like wipe it into that culture yeah
this is what they were essentially
trying to do yeah and uh like white
people yeah that's what they were doing
they tend to do that everywhere they're
doing that mississippi to us
you guys are white people yeah well now
the north after the [ __ ] civil war
the north came in and tried to [ __ ]
make everybody into yankees
where's the uh i'll make another drink
okay okay
all right
so all right so right around 1862.
uh this one the civil war was still
going on
now um the government at that point they
kind of like decided well we're going to
get rid of this navajo problem i guess
there had been like navajo had been like
raiding and like other people have been
raiding them and it was just kind of
like a big nightmare so they were kind
of like okay well we're going to do
something about this
so there's this guy named james
carlton
and he was the commander for the new
mexico military department
and he gave the orders to uh colonel kit
carson who's actually a very quite a
famous person in american history if you
went to school at least we learned about
him like when i was in school
um they basically told him
go into the navajo territory and get
them to surrender
like he was going to set up a surrender
uh you know to to them
so he goes there
in summer of 1863
and probably not surprisingly no nob
hoes showed up they're like [ __ ] that
we're not going to surrender it so none
of them showed up to this supposed
meeting where they were supposedly
supposed to surrender
so kit garson and his guys got mad and
they're like okay well um they go into
the territory they try to persuade the
navajos to surrender them and they're
like okay well they won't so they went
completely uh scorched earth is what
they decided to do they said we're gonna
um make them surrender
so what they did they got the utes uh
the the other tribe who did not like the
navajo um he got he kind of enlisted
their help he's like i need you to
capture as many navajos you can and they
basically
burned down their [ __ ] uh their
villages they like you know cut off
their supply lines they couldn't they
were trying to starve them out uh and
basically like force them into
surrendering
um and that worked really well because
the utes like i said who were another uh
tribe were very familiar with the navajo
they lived not that far away from them
and they were kind of like aware of
their uh their culture and like where
their strongholds were and [ __ ] like
that so january of 1864 there was like
this big huge assault um they basically
like burned down
all of their houses they took all they
killed other livestock
they captured a bunch of them if you try
to get away they killed you um some of
them did get away but not really that
many and it ended up being like really
cold they couldn't have any food so like
even the ones that got away like
eventually were kind of like forced to
surrender
after the surrender uh in 1864
came something called the long walk
um now this was
essentially like a deportation because
at this point where the navajo lived was
in uh what is now
uh arizona
um and part of new mexico and they lived
between what they called like the four
sacred mountains like that was their
sacred tribal lands so they made them
leave and um this is essentially and i
saw several uh sources call it
essentially an attempted ethnic cleanse
cleansing they were just trying to so
they marched them off the lands um all
of them whether it's pregnant ladies old
people children whatever there's like
you're gonna walk to your new area we're
driving you off your sacred lands and
we're gonna like make you walk there um
and it wasn't just one it was like 53 i
think like forced marches over a couple
of year period uh so this took 18 days
it was 300 miles
uh at least 200 people died on this
particular walk and they moved them
into like this 40 square mile area which
eventually had about 9 000 people on it
so they were there for a couple of years
finally in 1868 the navajo were allowed
to come back
to the government they actually gave
them back their ancestral lands i
believe that's the only time that that
happened in the history of the united
states i believe they were given 3.5 3.5
million acres something like that that
they had previously lived on so they
actually did give it back to them and
they allowed them to come back like
three years after the long walk after a
bunch of them died
so
considering how kind of shittily they
were treated it is amazing as
grandparents brought up that
when uh you know world war one world war
ii when that came around
the navajo and other tribes were um
quite willing to
uh join the army and fight for the
united states and uh indeed many of them
did like you said there i think that's
something that maybe a lot of people
don't know about like military history
of the united states is that a lot of
them were they were very very
over represented
um in regards to their population you
know what i'm saying yeah they were more
likely to join than any other ethnic
group
they're not very there weren't as many
of them right that's what i'm saying at
a lot higher rate yeah so when i was in
each company always had one or two
and that's [ __ ]
fantastic when you think of the how few
of them there were
yeah because there really weren't a lot
of company of a hundred men there's like
two or three of them
you know yeah and they came
you know you know
from tribal areas you know is where
they're coming from now they were also
islanders pacific islanders and um
micronesians
and the micronesians were almost kind of
like mercenaries somehow they were able
to join the us army as a profession
there's a lot of stuff you know
right now people talking about about
mercenaries need to send us these
mercenaries to death well [ __ ] you could
be descendants in [ __ ] 10 of the us
army to death because 10 of them
technically are mercenaries from ireland
from you know you don't have to be an
american citizen to join the us army
that's a misconception yeah as long as
you're not a criminal they'll let you in
you're not gonna get a secret clearance
well yeah that's a whole other thing
yeah but you know so we had guys from
ireland
um
we had guys from um
samoa micronesia
this is in the 90s trying to think of
any other weird countries
because it's just a weird kind of call
it a weird country
but just a country you don't you don't
realize like what the hell are you doing
in here they you know well you don't
meet that many people in your day-to-day
life i mean well ireland's not weird
i've met irish people in my life but you
know it's like why isn't he in the
british army you know i [ __ ] out he
enjoyed a big army you know
um
yeah oh it'll oh i forgot j i forgot
lots of [ __ ] el salvador
because we had a lot of contras guys who
were ex one of my squad leaders was an
ex contra and his wife was a contra
and they uh they came out of that school
of america i think was el salvador yeah
salvador and um
man we used to hear stories about his
wife his wife was a contra but she
couldn't serve in the us army his wife
had killed several dozen people she was
a [ __ ] badass
um you know and evidently it wasn't
wasn't friendly [ __ ] that she was doing
they were doing interrogations and stuff
so
i didn't really get all the details i
was on the impression that she [ __ ]
tortured people and killed him
sandinistas
yeah because they were
if you had got contras in your unit
they were
being hidden there
in other words they were rescued they
were evacuated
to safety
you know what is what you're talking
about
we created them so we had to take care
of them afterwards because they kind of
lost that that war you couldn't let them
stay there they'd get killed
so they kind of
they stayed in army service forever they
brought them into our army they took
care of them
keep them on post
gave new identities and [ __ ]
thank you bryce what oh yeah we're
finally getting a super chat up in this
[ __ ] i forgot all about super
chats we haven't had a super chat in
about what a week
i forgot we've made super chat
what's he saying
my understanding is they viewed it as
working with not for the us government
in defense of their lands yeah it does
seem like the ones that they talked to
on the documentaries that i saw um
mostly seemed like there's like well you
know we live here these are our lands so
yeah we're gonna defend it so i think
that it wasn't so much oh we're working
for like you know uh an entity that
[ __ ] us over yeah no um so much as
like we're defending our
our homeland and our families that's
kind of how yeah because u.s army would
come in us government come in and give
them uniforms trainings and equipment
and say defend your area here's the flag
yeah defend your area under our banner
same thing xerxes was doing you know
[ __ ]
was he was trying to do that for the
[ __ ] spartans you know
you know it's joined my side and your
[ __ ] banner will fly high above
europa you know like i said i'll put you
in charge we were doing that kind of
stuff yeah
uh
shifting alliances and but
you know native americans were they were
americans
you know well yeah they were here before
they were here
so
yeah
so don't be saying i was like oh they're
not they're over they're gone okay
technology i was here several thousand
years before yeah
and the convenience of technologies came
to them before the government got a hold
of them
so they knew that good things were
coming [ __ ] like steel and pots and pans
and guns and horses and well they
largely seemed very practical yeah just
kind of like hey whatever some good [ __ ]
that we can use man yeah handed over so
they traded and had money
you know and then the government come up
and [ __ ] them over but that same
government was [ __ ] us over too
you know [ __ ] and a lot of it wasn't
government too a lot of his private
businesses
[ __ ] railroad company was out of
control they'd [ __ ] over anybody oh good
lord we should do a show about [ __ ]
railroads yeah people don't realize
there's a whole that's a whole
hornet's nest yeah
you don't realize that there wasn't
really any kind of federal government as
you would know it until world war ii
thank you straw dog seven okay thank you
very much he guilted him into it yeah
it was in his mind crying for it there
was not a central government as you
would know it until world war ii it
really didn't become totally solidified
until that time everything was local
the real power players
were corporations
corporations were more powerful than the
railroad had its own justice system its
own army ran its own courts and
sentenced people to death yeah they
killed people yeah and they got away
with it lots of people
corporations are much more powerful than
governments they still are
and during world war ii the corporations
and the [ __ ] u.s government merged
into one thing that's very dangerous
general eisenhower president eisenhower
was warned warned us in his farewell
speech
about [ __ ] a monster that had been
created with [ __ ] unwarranted powers
and it's
and it's all coming to fruition it's an
oligarchy
the pilot the political [ __ ] is just
window dressing to give you the illusion
of choice you don't have a choice it
owns both parties
and a populist uprising will be crushed
as fascism
but they're fascist that's what it is
fascism is the merger of [ __ ] state
and corporate powers
you know and then throw in a little bit
of throw in a little bit of monarchy
because they're all the same families
you know they're just real good at
hiding what they are and uh
anyway
the indians and just americans and
everything were kind of [ __ ]
especially out in [ __ ] unclaimed
territory where there wasn't any rule of
law no way to enforce anything no
telecommunications
you were [ __ ] out there you had to
[ __ ] watch your own back
you know a gang of [ __ ] benjitos
could come and get you a whole bunch of
[ __ ] cowboys and [ __ ] outlaws
could jump on you indian tribes jumping
on each other or a damn [ __ ]
corporate [ __ ] army could come in
you know with a railroad behind it and
[ __ ] your whole town up
there were mass graves along the side of
those [ __ ]
where the railroad went
they found mass graves [ __ ] dead
bodies with [ __ ] signs of bullet
holes in them we're talking hundreds of
them right on the side with not a peep
of what had happened
all them [ __ ] irish dudes irish and
chinese dead
stacked up on top of each other like
several hundred of them and no they
didn't need them anymore not a peep of
what happened nope i think it was a
revolt
well yeah i'm sure they were working
them and not paying them
they got them down that's what i'm
saying send them some more send us some
more irish in chinese
that's what happened yeah no no
witnesses
and probably the pinkertons there's
security companies they had a railroad
security company [ __ ] more
[ __ ] more better trained and [ __ ]
better armed than the us army
startup 78 said speaking of native
americans they used to have a communal
way through their rituals of
reintegrating their warriors into normal
society after seeing heavy combat
consequently ptsd wasn't an issue
see that's really interesting i wonder
if maybe that's why
we're going to date though well no but i
mean maybe because they had a way of
dealing with it i think the reason that
there was so much of that
like alcoholism and you know uh domestic
abuse and things like that going on with
veterans of the world war one of world
war ii
was probably not because they were bad
guys or anything like that it was
because
there was no framework in place for them
to
talk about the [ __ ] or process it in any
way that would be like healthy for them
or purge it world war one and world war
ii and vietnam did not resemble each
other though in any way
and the veterans weren't the same
that's true there are nothing nothing
alike world war one was mostly about
sitting in a damn trench being eaten to
death by lice and just enduring shelling
oh my god did you guys see that
documentary
holy [ __ ] the one that um
was it peter jackson that did it like
that world war one would remember we saw
that the theater
yeah that world war one document it was
all like colorized footage like from the
time holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
those guys came back with a lot of
problems because it was a lot of pent up
stuff yeah because they never really
fought they just sat there and got
killed
um and then when they got out when they
went back home nobody even knew that it
happened
it was world war one was not a thing
the when they went back home the public
didn't know that it didn't even work did
couldn't didn't really know what world
war one was
because there wasn't a modern media
so they had no idea what the dudes would
want went through yeah their idea of
what war was you got on a horse and you
rode around shot at other people there
wasn't any of that world war one right
yeah they didn't even have a good grasp
of what air air aerial combat was they
the average person to wait yeah i mean
you didn't see it it wasn't something
that you dealt with every day like you
said we didn't have like a mass media
right now it is so it took a few decades
really
people didn't really know what world war
one was until the 30s
and there was a long time after yeah so
can you imagine like going through the
[ __ ] because like i said please see that
peter jackson documentary because i mean
you can read about world war one all day
long like i you know cause i've read a
lot about it but
seeing it like seeing the actual footage
and seeing it colorized and it looks
like modern um it's [ __ ] up i mean
just like seeing it right in front of
your face and to go through that
and then to come back home and to have
absolutely nobody get it like you can't
even tell anybody about it because
they're just like whatever like they
don't even know what you're talking
about that's what i'm saying and it's
just like it must be so isolating they
said that you felt like you were a
different species of human beings yeah i
think some of them said that on that
documentary and that you were yeah you
were lucky to find another world war one
veteran because then you could actually
talk about how stupid other people were
and how little they knew what had
happened
and um you know because they didn't know
you had it was world war one was
confined along the damn
no man's land
it was confined along a front it didn't
affect the rest of society
world war ii was made a different kind
of uh veteran
it depended on what theater you were in
and how long you were in combat
but
when it came to american
veterans
they actually i think suffered the least
when it came to psychological stuff
because they had a way of venting
you know what i mean they actually got
to do things some guys reported that
they loved it that it was just riding
around in armored vehicles shooting
stuff up and having exciting tank
battles and well and the american troops
entered much later yeah
right the guys who [ __ ] really
got [ __ ] up where the where the
germans the germans basically fought to
the last man they there there are they
didn't really have ptsd problems because
they're all dead most of them they all
died you can't have ptsd when you're
yeah you can't have ptsd when you did
and those
pilots flew until they died
and um and then the russians with the
russians was going to say the russians
the russians the entire civilization had
ptsd because i think uh
the [ __ ]
germans killed tens and tens of millions
of civilians civilians that's what i'm
saying through there they were
they were [ __ ] brought as civilians
alive in churches and [ __ ] burning
down the whole because
germany's war against russia was a war
of annihilation they didn't want
anything from russia they just wanted to
vacate it with people
you can't negotiate with that okay
they just come in to kill you
they want the land it was a war of
annihilation they wouldn't they wanted
they wanted to make
russia their country
so
the civilians were the turret targets
and uh they that's
that's why russia is very tough to this
day they know warfare in ways that
americans and europe well you're some
europeans that know it but
they the russians know warfare in ways
that american civilians could never know
warfare those dudes are [ __ ] masters
at it especially
wars of maneuvers in other words
maneuver combat combined arms combat
they're real good at that they're not
like us they're not dependent on
aircraft they don't need that they'll do
it on the ground man-to-man
and they're good at it
as
the world is seeing now they're very
good
and um
they're tough they don't care about
casualties casualties part of war
you know what i mean
a hundred thousand dead no problem
that's that's nothing compared to what
happened you know world war ii that's
their thinking they can absorb [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of casualties now there's not
as many as russians as there used to be
though that's the that's the that's the
difference there used to be a lot more
russians but the germans killed so many
of them that's what i'm saying that's
why there's not that many russians
because of that
uh oracle said yeah that was peter
jackson yeah that documentary i was
talking about uh she said the
colorization isn't so much the fix as it
is correcting the speed of the film in
my opinion yeah it is stabilizing it
yeah because we're used to early film
she says having that herky-jerky action
going so people don't look quite real in
that footage but jackson's work made the
film subject look like people not
mechanical dolls yeah yeah i think that
was like more than the colorization so i
think that was what was because i had
seen some of that footage before
but yeah it's just like seeing anything
from back then it's like you know those
are real people like intellectually but
it doesn't quite look real
the veterans that got the worst were
were american vietnam veterans
everyone kind of got the worst because
that was a war
where um
the infantry was being used as bait
you sent them out on patrol you wait for
them to get shot at
when they get shot at a couple of them
get killed
they call for air support or artillery
strikes
jets come they drop some bombs
artillery shoots some [ __ ]
artillery shells into the bushes
and then once that hits they run out
there and see if they can find it about
any bodies and they usually can't find
anything and then they go back to the
next patrol and they just keep doing
that over and over again so it's a war
of walking around in a damn jungle
getting a couple of your guys killed
over and over and over and never really
seeing the enemy
and that drive you out that would drive
you up the [ __ ] wall because you're
not you're not accomplishing anything
and that's that and then they get home
and people [ __ ] treat them like [ __ ]
when they got drafted they didn't they
didn't
volunteer for it
calm baby killers and [ __ ]
now
their bad [ __ ] did happen there every
now and then but uh
it was just a bad place everybody was
frustrated
oh yeah we shouldn't have been there no
it should have been yeah
well the whole the whole thing is really
there should there's
all those wars really had nothing to do
with the united states it was always
about making some rich guys in the
united states richer
and the american people didn't really
get much out of it
i would we really did we should have
definitely not been in world war one
and i questioned whether or not we
should have been in world war ii
but the japanese did bomb pearl harbor
well so you had to do something to the
japanese
but europe really was none of our
business the russians had that
russians could have taken care of they
did most of the work
linwood said watched episode 257 when
you guys went off script about chocolate
and old style candy necco wafers jenny
said they tasted like third grade chalk
dust and sadness kind of they they do i
like them though anyway especially
especially though that's because you
like gross things oh she as far as candy
is concerned you look gross i really
like the uh
the the black licorice flavored ones
those are all
these flavors yeah
[Laughter]
i'm not a big like i said i'm not a real
big fruit candy fan right like i like
starburst i like
[ __ ] like that but before i get too far
off the subject about we shouldn't have
not been in any of those wars and i've
joined up to go to one of them the first
gulf war
it seemed to make sense at the time
uh but looking back on it there was
another one we got light on we got light
into and other people got rich off of it
and they told us that that would help
the americans you know keep the gas
prices [ __ ] reasonable nah didn't
have anything to do with that of course
not no it was it was about making money
and uh
a lot of people are waking up from a
very long delusion and it's the delusion
of [ __ ] empire building
[ __ ] uh regime change
the delusion of globalism and all that
kind of [ __ ] and the the the delusion of
nation building you cannot go into
somebody else's country and tell them
how to handle their [ __ ] business you
cannot make them accept your form of
[ __ ] government it just doesn't work
never
you wouldn't like it if a foreign
country came in you came in here in the
united states and told you how to [ __ ]
look your government sucks here's a new
form of government adopt ours you would
say now [ __ ] that
and you know it's against human nature
to do that there's too many different
cultures and religions involved that's
what there's not going to be any empire
there's not going to be any globalism or
anything that's that's not going to work
it's going to go back to like it was
which is
tribal cultures customs beliefs and
religions like it like it's been for
thousands of years because it doesn't
benefit you as a person to have a system
like that
and you're not willing to send your
children
to go oil the jaws of a war machine you
have to have to force that into
existence because you don't you don't
have children okay most of you
and you're not gonna be able to import
these people from central america and
send them over there to fight your wars
so you can have a big global assist it's
not gonna happen and it's gonna fall
apart it's falling apart right now it
was all a delusion
nation building only worked with japan
and germany because we basically nearly
wiped them out in a genocidal war where
we were bombing their women and their
children while they slept in bed
and when the war was over they were
totally dependent upon us for food
so yeah
japan now has christmas
at what cost
63 [ __ ] japanese cities burned to the
ground
okay women and children it wasn't worth
it
you know
hate to break your hearts
but uh so it's going back the way it was
a multi-polar world
okay let's go
judd says my wife always tells me i like
grandma and grandpa candy well now some
grandma and grandpa candy i'm i'm on
board i love grandma garrett like were
there's original that's grandpa candy i
like that
um that kind of like ribbon candy i kind
of like that but
you know those little weird crunchy
peanut butter bar what the [ __ ] are
those called i always get about
halloween not bitter honey no i don't
know well bit of honey are good too
they're you always getting a halloween
they're like a little rectangle and
they're like kind of white on the
outside but they have like peanut but
they're like a little bit of like a
butter finger inside but not quite
no it's not an abba zaba
they're just like they're independent
it's kind of like a butterfinger
yeah i just said that okay i literally
just said that like five seconds ago
um but they're like individually wrapped
i always got them at halloween those are
good that's probably like grandma candy
yeah
but other than that
uh camp guy said i love homemade peanut
brittle oh man i haven't had peanut
butter in a long time i [ __ ] love
peanut brittle
all right so we gonna get into this go
ahead good all right
uh so yeah so since you were asking uh
more than 12 000
american indians served in world war one
which was at the time
25
of the male native american population
at that time a quarter of all native
american males
uh
fought and served in world war one
uh in world war ii
when the total native american
population was less than 400 thousand
uh they estimate that 44 000 indian men
and 800
native american women served in the uh
armed forces
so code talking now
usually when you're talking about code
talking it's usually native american
languages um but there have been some
attempts with other
lesser known really any kind of like
lesser-known language will work because
i've seen like some sort of limited
kind of attempts using stuff like mask
or welsh or something like that that
doesn't have a lot of native speakers
but usually when you're talking about uh
code talkers it's usually native
american languages mostly because most
of them
are not written languages uh they're you
know it's an oral tradition and very
very few people outside of the tribes
that speak them
know that they exist even or
you know you can't really learn them you
know what i mean because there's no
books or anything like that guys
you got to grow up talking it pretty
much um yeah so outsiders like very very
rarely and like i said i think like even
a lot of people like didn't even know
that they existed that there were so
many of them
now interestingly uh so
during world war one
now
it turned out that the german forces
during world war one
uh most of them could speak very good
english
and didn't really have too much problem
intercepting codes
uh you know what i mean because
the whole thing yes like the whole code
thing goes back a long way but there's
always code breakers and pretty much
every code other than the navajo code
talkers code
has been broken because everything
relied on
different types of codes that could be
broken if somebody came up with it
then
you could figure it out even if you used
one that was based on like because they
used ones that were based on
like books like a particular book and
you had to get a particular page and
they they tried to like you know encode
things in a way that other people
couldn't figure out but
usually someone would figure it out
eventually
so what ended up happening though
because a lot of messages were being
decoded there was a guy
who was an american officer and his name
was colonel uh alfred bloor
and he was in the 142nd infantry in
france
and he happened to notice that there
were two guys who were actually choctaw
and they were speaking to each other
in their native language
and he thinks to himself
wow i've never heard that language
before i can't understand them
and he knew that they were choctaw and
he's like i bet
most other people wouldn't be able to
understand them either
and maybe we can like do something with
that
so uh so basically he kind of went to
them and sort of like proposed hey you
know maybe we could do like a code like
based on your native language because
i'm imagining not a lot of people speak
that
so him and the two guys they
tested the code um and they basically i
don't think they did anything super
complicated but what they did was they
did a test where they had a couple of
messages that were you know analogous to
what you know would be a real message
like that and basically put it into the
choctaw language
uh and it worked in the tests so it
actually had its first combat test in
october of 1918
and they were doing this kind of like
withdrawal of two companies of the
second battalion like from one french
town to another
and it worked uh the germans they heard
they picked up the message but there's
like what the [ __ ] does that they
couldn't figure it out uh and it was
just like this surprise that it happened
so he's like okay well that was a
success then
they also uh happened that they captured
a german soldier during this time an
officer and they asked him about it and
he just said yeah we didn't we didn't
know uh what the [ __ ] they were saying
we didn't figure that out so they
thought that was like pretty cool now
they're obviously as i said before there
had been a lot of native americans
serving in world war one um and they had
been utilized in other roles like a lot
of them were message runners and uh
stuff like that
um
so for a little while
they put um
choctaw
people in each of the kind of like uh
battalions so they could like transmit
messages across the radio just using the
choctaw language i don't know if they
did
like they did with the navajo code
talkers later where they kind of like
did a double up on the code where it
wasn't just
them speaking in their native language
they would do like other things too like
to make it more complicated so they're
battalion level battalion level rtos
yeah yeah sly knows what that is
so they're up at the red they were
handed out by the regimental
headquarters
yeah so okay i didn't know i didn't know
if they were platoon level or company
level but at this point
battalion level
battalions about
400 guys
in this area might be a little bit more
maybe 500.
the company was bigger back then
maybe six
okay
just trying to wrap my head around it
yeah so for every 600 guys there's one
code talker yeah yeah i mean there
wasn't a [ __ ] i don't think there was
like a [ __ ] ton of choctaw but there was
enough of them that like they had
because like i said they always had to
have them in pairs because like you had
to have one guy with this and then you
had to have somebody like translate it
at the other end you know what i mean
regimen has three battalions okay so
each battalion has its own rto
regimental headquarters has one so
that's that's how they're getting the
messages out to the to the battalions
battalions four companies
companies for platoons platoons
in this era probably about 50 men
probably
30 to 50.
yeah
so yeah so after the war like the guy
that kind of like came up with the idea
he was just like yeah this worked out
really good um he's like the only
shortcoming and this was another thing
that they uh kind of found with the
navajo code talkers too but they
overcame it in other ways
was that obviously the choctaw language
didn't have any words for stuff like
machine gun or
you know or any or submarine or anything
like that so they had to like make some
stuff up metal fish iron fish yeah that
was one of the ones that the that the
navajo came up with but yeah so it's
like they just kind of have like if you
had like they they would just say like
big gun or uh i think a little gun shoot
fast was machine gun
so it's like but they i mean they worked
around it you know because obviously
they didn't have words for that also
during world war one uh you had cherokee
soldiers who were in the u.s 30th
infantry division division and they uh
transmitted messages actually um during
the second battle of the of the psalm in
france yeah and um that was in september
of 1918.
now as i mentioned earlier uh
german authorities uh you know coming
into world war ii
knew about this from world war one
um
matter of fact uh goebbels himself
declared native americans are fellow
aryans gee thanks yeah so um yeah
i told you guys about that earlier many
people didn't believe it jesus christ
it's the germans of the bent cross were
silly man
they were very silly you guys are silly
you couldn't really take anything they
said about racial policies uh uh you
couldn't take it seriously because they
just made [ __ ] up as they went along
they anybody they liked they declared
aryans didn't matter what color they
were they just liked you okay you're an
arian they're making you an eye you're
one of the guys make you a honorary
cracker that's what they're [ __ ]
that's what they would do make your
honorary honky nazis are ridiculous yeah
people people take it more seriously
than it really was they well i didn't
take it i take them killing millions of
people yeah i take that pretty seriously
but their beliefs were yeah ridiculous
yeah their beliefs were ridiculous they
they didn't take them that seriously
they just made [ __ ] up as they were they
just wanted to kill people and found
they wanted to destroy enemies and take
over yeah and they just had their own
[ __ ] way of explaining and describing
what they were doing and it all depended
on whatever day it was you were asking
them it was not
a heart they weren't they weren't going
from a bible or going okay modern people
think about well we have to have a
system
all right so you're impo they did not
have a system it was not really a system
not really
it
the best [ __ ] quote i've ever heard
from a german
was telling a story when he was in he
was a little kid
with his dad in the living room
listening to the radio
and they were hearing listening to the
fuhrer and they were listening to
gobbles and gobbles was going on and on
about national socialism
and he asked his dad he says dad what is
national socialism anyway
and his dad [ __ ] answered the
question correctly he said national
socialism is the will of the fuhrer
that's all it was it was the will of the
fear whatever the future told you that's
what it was
we'll see in a way that's kind of like
religious thinking too so it's just like
what's good well what god says what does
god say
exactly and it was done that way on
purpose to give them the flexibility the
the the message behind the bat cross was
sit down and shut the [ __ ] up that's
what it was don't sit down and shut the
[ __ ] up we're just gonna do whatever we
want and we will justify it after the
fact yep by whatever we pull out of our
ass exactly
which i kind of feel like it's about
most people operate
sadly
i think that's most of the world well
that's what i'm saying that's it's sad
but that is kind of yeah
[ __ ] up that's what it means that's how
most people are doing
but so yeah so that's the thing so the
germans actually were aware
that in world war one um native
americans had been used like their
languages had been used like to code
messages they were aware of that
so what they did um
going into i believe it was like in 1940
or thereabouts uh until like early 1940s
they sent
a team of anthropologists
to the us
to learn native american languages
before world war ii broke out
so they were thinking ahead
uh but i guess they didn't really
understand how many
native american tribes there are and how
many native american languages there are
uh because when they got here
they were like well
wait which ones do you want us to learn
because there's like hundreds
and they found the task way too
difficult that's what i mean like a lot
of the native american languages
obviously this is generalization because
they're all very different from one
another but a lot of them if you didn't
grow up speaking them
um they're very very difficult to learn
some of them have
similarities with asian languages in the
sense that
a lot of it
sometimes like one particular
phoneme or like one kind of uh word or
something like that will mean
a bunch of different things depending on
how you say it like the tone that you
say it in
so because it's an oral language so it's
meant to be spoken to one another so a
lot of it is in
is in the sound of it like how long you
hold a vowel for example like it could
be mean this thing or it can mean that
thing depending on how many seconds you
hold the vowel or whatever so
it's a very complicated language to
learn if you hadn't uh they're very
complicated languages to learn if you
didn't and like i said most of them are
not written so there wasn't like there
was a there was a book you could go to
and like learn it so uh the germans they
they had a hard time
and ultimately like gave up on it
now
because uh us authorities though they
figured out like what the little nazis
were up to they're like oh [ __ ] they're
like over here trying to figure out like
how to speak various native american
languages and so for that reason they
were kind of like well maybe we
shouldn't do the code talker thing
because they're on to it um you know
even though they did i don't think they
really knew like how much they learned
but they were just kind of like well
then we probably shouldn't deploy it
like to any great degree because you
know they might be able to like break it
but they did use it uh in a limited
capacity
so the us army was actually the first
branch that started uh recruiting code
talkers uh in 1940 they started they
went into a place like oklahoma and
stuff like that and started recruiting
people like comanche chippewa
uh hopi like a bunch of different tribes
um and they wanted them to be code
talkers
so they would have kind of like all
these uh recruiters that were going
around like i said particularly like in
the south southwest like area
um and some of them like some of the
code talkers didn't even uh and were
like weren't even technically in the
military they were just kind of like
contractors i guess like working on the
outside of it um and some of them but
some of them like enlisted in the armed
services some like got drafted as i
mentioned earlier some that uh enlisted
were actually like too young to enlist
like some were uh you know teenagers
some were 15. actually a couple of them
were
older than like because some of them
were like in their
mid to late 30s which is a little bit
because i think they don't really want
them after like 35 or so
but some were a little bit older than
that but they enlisted anyway
so initially in very very early like
world war ii like early 1940s
so you got at first 17 comanche code
talkers
um now three of these were not able to
uh go across the atlantic when they got
deployed like to europe so they actually
ended up taking 14 of them
now uh so 14 of them using the comanche
language uh
to to transmit codes actually um
took part in the normandy invasion they
were in the fourth infantry division in
uh europe
so what they had come up with what they
did
was they had put together like a
vocabulary of 250
code terms uh and these were essentially
like i said they were kind of like you
know words for various things
that they needed like communicated just
translated into their own language and
again they had a thing where
because a lot of native american
languages didn't have words for
tanks or things like that so they'd have
to come up with some kind of like phrase
uh you know to convey that so uh you
know like for example like the word for
tank they would use the word for turtle
um you know for a bomber they would say
pregnant bird which is actually like
pretty clever when you think about it uh
they called a machine gun a sewing
machine
and they called i love this one they
called adolf hitler crazy white man
crazy white man i'm like what are you
gonna have to narrow that down a little
bit but when they said crazy crazy white
man into the comanche language that's
who they were talking about they were
talking about hitler
so uh again like i said they usually
worked in pairs so you had two comanche
code talkers assigned to each regiment
and then the rest of them uh were at the
fourth the fourth infantry division
headquarters
now so
they landed on uh utah beach actually in
uh on june 6 1944 and started like
transmitting messages from there some of
them got wounded but actually none of
them got killed
so
shortly after this other branches uh us
marines most famously and the navy um
kind of followed a year or two later and
this is where we got into the navajo
code dockers like i said probably the
most famous of the lot
and how this ended up happening kind of
similar to how it happened in world war
one
you have this guy named philip johnston
and he was uh
a civil engineer uh he worked for the
city of los angeles and he was a
civilian
now
what had happened with him was that he
was he had served in world war one but
he was actually the son of missionaries
that had lived on a navajo reservation
so he had actually grown up he was a
white kid but he had grown up on the
navajo reservation and spoke fluent
navajo one of the very very few uh white
people to do so
so
it occurred to him
that well you know not that many people
speak the navajo language other than the
navajo so it's like we could really use
that like you know to encode messages so
he decided he was going to go uh to
the you know to the military and like
see if they would would do it
so basically so like i said after pearl
harbor happened and a bunch of navajo
enlisted in the armed forces
um
you know this was kind of like a good
time for this to happen
now
as i mentioned navajo in particular like
many native american languages uh is a
very very complex
uh
language the grammar is very complex
and even with its kind of closest
um
relatives like language relatives it is
not uh intelligible to even people that
you know that whose language is like
quite closely related
uh it was also at the time unwritten uh
it has since been written down but it
wasn't at the time
so basically philip johnston was like um
you know not a lot of people speak this
it hasn't been written down so it's not
like anybody can find a code book or
anything like that um so i think this
will be like a good thing
it basically uh
just had very complex syntax as i said
it relied a lot on
tonal uh
things like i said like you know
particularly one thing where it was like
a vowel if you said it like for this
many like for this long it meant this or
if it was longer than that it meant this
or it was like really short it meant
this so it's like the same sound could
mean lots of different things depending
on the tone that you set it in uh which
like i said a lot of asian languages are
like that as well
um so yeah so
he goes to
uh early 1942
he goes to the commanding general of the
amphibious corps who was major general
uh clayton vogel
and
he kind of proposed the idea to them
which they liked
they're like okay well we're gonna test
this out so what they did
was they set up
like simulated combat conditions you
know what i mean like you're being
shelled you're being this that and the
other thing and here are some messages
that are just like messages which you
would actually convey
um and you have to send it like under
like a really high stress situation to
see if it would work
uh it worked like gangbusters the dudes
they had in there
uh they said they could transmit and
decode a three-line message in 20
seconds
uh they had for the record uh they had
code you know code breaking machines
back then which took about half an hour
so 20 seconds a lot better
uh so yeah and these dudes could do it
like super fast they could do it under
stressful situations uh without making
any mistakes
so they're like well obviously uh this
is much much better because like i said
the navajos they had a long oral
tradition so they didn't have any
problem at all like memorizing [ __ ] like
right away they didn't write anything
down let me say some people are saying
well they need to use
african click language this time you
know
all this is obsolete
because um
nowadays you have encode decode and
[ __ ] scramblers
for radios now that make all this stuff
obsolete this was in a time where the
enemy could hear your broadcast they
could hear it yeah it was just regular
radio i mean anybody could pick it up
yeah so you have to encode that yeah
somehow you don't need that anymore you
can [ __ ] scramble anything
and then you can unscramble things but
then you can also compress things
and
nowadays you don't even really need
radio
i mean
i know for a fact that some real
sensitive [ __ ]
information was given
from one unit to the next
having to do with stuff that was
happening in the middle east
not through radio at all but for the
through the chat rooms of a [ __ ] uh
video game that had that was open to the
public
just because
what are the chances of someone being
being there in that particular live
online game it's the hide and play
inside they hit him
dudes [ __ ] because if you're trying
to be sneaky or people like well what
are you trying to be sneaky about yeah
just talking to each other audio through
a damn video game in the middle of a
[ __ ] live
live action video game
and you know sensitive material went
through that and that was a
way of
[ __ ] transmitting the message
between um
they were they were [ __ ] contractors
you know [ __ ] security contractors in
an echelon above reality you know
outside even the army the army didn't
even know about it
so
what you can do today is just
unbelievable compared to what you can do
in the 40s yeah yeah i mean the
technology now is just kind of like off
the table all this [ __ ] you don't really
like need to do this anymore all this
shit's obsolete
i mean nowadays people use like codes
and stuff for args that's about it yeah
[Laughter]
like for [ __ ] you got secure
communications now so you just don't
need it yeah
but it's still cool that like they i
mean they just like had to work around
it right like you said it was just over
radio yeah anybody with a radio you
could pick that [ __ ] up yeah including
your enemies they're like oh
what's that you say you're delivering
this whole thing of like [ __ ]
artillery over here right you're moving
your troops over there you only have to
do this when you know that every one of
your transmissions is being
recorded and intercepted
and then they're going to work on it
yeah even if it's in code because most
of the codes were broken eventually yeah
because like i said if you can come up
with a code
someone else can figure it out right
eventually this
this strategic sys this strategic
situation is no longer no longer out
there
all [ __ ] real clandestine
communication is done and [ __ ]
scrabbled compressed and given across
some medium that is not radio like i
said in the chat in the live chat room
of a [ __ ]
halo tournament
you know something like that
no one would ever know
well now they do because you just said
it
[Laughter]
well that was a long time ago i know i'm
just kidding so
they're blowing their cover
there's so many places to communicate an
enemy government can't intercept
everything everywhere
so you can just
hide in plain sight because there are so
many venues
you know i mean there's so much
information out there that it's just
kind of like holy [ __ ] you could just
like trade messages on like some obscure
blog somewhere about [ __ ] who knows
what in this day everything was on the
am band or fm band
yeah
they just had to work within the
limitations of their technology at the
time which you know
i just shortwave radio i just always
like admire their [ __ ] innovation man
because like i said they they didn't
know any better it's like this is what
we got and we got to like work around it
somehow it's like nowadays it's just
kind of like well what did they just do
this and that the other thing well they
couldn't do that yeah and they didn't
they didn't know any different you know
because that's all they had and my
little baofang radio i can bring a
couple of radios in here and show to you
[ __ ] outperforms anything i was ever
given in the army in the uh 90s and it's
this big let me show i'll show you my
radius hold on how much were they i'll
show each one's different
he got these little radios
and
um he was trying to do a test either
because we pick up because i guess some
of our neighbors like in black bear
reserve i think that they have some too
because every now and then we pick up
like some kids like running around like
talking into the [ __ ] and like jumping
in the pool and whatnot um they must
have got them for christmas or something
but uh tom wanted to test the range on
it the other day and so he gave me one
of the radios and then he had one of the
radios and he just went walking like all
down the neighborhood and stuff like
that when he was talking and it was like
crystal clear when he was like a long
time like a long way away so i thought
that was like really funny
yeah this here
look at that little bitty thing
that's a baofeng
it's the uh the uv5
r r which is a little ham radio
okay this thing is fully programmable
can listen to two channels at once
uh it can scan it can do all kinds of
neat things
you can program it and pookie likes to
chew on the antenna i can
pick up repeaters in my area and listen
to people talking in new england
out of this thing
when i bought this it came with a
battery and a couple of antennas was
twenty dollars
yep i can change the power from a watt
all the way up to five watts
my army radio i was issued was a one
watt radio and weighed almost 25 pounds
which isn't that crazy you could like
put that in your [ __ ] pocket right
so you can buy these off of uh what is
that gonna be alive you even
this is the same radio in a waterproof
container
with better motorola style
uh attachments and everything but this
one's fully waterproof and this one was
only 35.
okay
now this is an expensive one this is an
ocean
this is another ham radio this one was
about 150 at the time that i bought it
it's also a 5 watt radio
but just a lot nicer a lot more features
on it
although knowing what i know now
this one for 35 probably be the way to
go and i have them both in ham and in
gmrs which is kind of like the new
version i mean they're handy to have
particularly like in in hurricanes
if the power gets knocked out this
little one right here with a little
bitty short stubby antenna that i got on
there
i tested it with jenny and i walked down
that yeah that's what i was selling she
sat right here in this office
and i walked down the road almost a half
a mile and was able to get her with this
one with the other little short antenna
and it was just clear as day throughout
the years
and um
in an emergency if there's no cell
phones you use this
now would i take this on a mission
no i don't really trust that battery
real low temperatures i'd rather
take this one it's a better battery and
fully uh
waterproof and it's a 35 radio that's
better than what they issued me in the
army
well see everything is getting better
like all the technologies i wouldn't i
wouldn't go back to like the old days we
had some shitty crap back and the one
that i had in the army [ __ ] had to
carry it in a [ __ ] rucksack and
weighed 20 something pounds it would
just wear you out with all those [ __ ]
batteries
and it was a fraction of the power
although you know really the power isn't
that important because you're talking to
people that are close to you anyway you
don't want anybody here in it
you'll be blasting out all those damn
radio waves startup 78 said did you guys
ever cover number stations we did it was
a long time ago we did a show called
eerie espionage yeah and we talked about
i think we talked about summerton man
and install woman and i think we talked
about number stations also i think on
that show it was a very very early one
it was one of the first ones yeah
there's not a whole lot that really
wouldn't fill a whole show the number
stations it's easy to know what number
stations are i mean they're creepy
sounding yeah and i think for a long
time like if you just kind of came
across it randomly it would be super
creepy because they do sound creepy yeah
even though i knew even though i know
what they are right um it still sounds
really creepy
but again there's kind of not really
like a lot of use for that i feel like
not anymore not anymore
i think there's a couple still going for
whatever reason but yeah it's probably
cuba
yeah maybe
i don't know
i looked into it you just don't need it
you don't need short rave radio anymore
like you used to there's too many but
the internet
yeah has uh kind of made that obsolete
but like i said radio is a good backup
tammy said tom ends up in the keys can
you hear me now yeah yeah
okay yeah he's gonna walk to the keys
yeah yeah that would take a while
uh bunny data said i used to have a
scanner uh police scanner but they
changed went to hd but it was neat to
listen to yeah you can't i used to be a
dispatcher uh you can't yeah you can
they actually on the dan bell show the
other night there's an app you just
download an app into your phone and you
can like listen to police games you're
listening
yeah yeah okay yeah his live stream okay
so it's an app
yeah you just downloaded an app to your
phone like a police scanner app and it
picks up all the [ __ ] you can't listen
to the cops on a radio anymore
because they're uh they're digital yeah
they're on digital they're yeah so it's
an app you just do it through your phone
because that's what they were doing okay
because stan was like
uh he told um who's his little buddy
that he's his friend that he's always
with the the kid with the glasses
yeah it's not dylan is it no africa
maybe his name's dylan but yeah but they
were in the car like driving around
baltimore and he's like download the
police scanner apps like see if we can
find some exciting like shooting or
something yeah
so it's like they downloaded the police
scanner after they were driving around
looking for crimes yeah
i didn't watch the whole thing because
it was like three hours but i was just
like watching some of it and i was like
laughing but yeah you can just download
he downloaded like two seconds and he
was like listen to the police scanner so
yeah that's what you do you just listen
to it just like everything else
everything's an app on your phone yeah
buddy stay in the army we had a code but
could change the other yeah it was
called the soi
that was for encode decode used to do
the same thing that was standard if just
stuff
um they that's what
those number stations are doing
they're giving out
a block of numbers the same time
it's traffic is always the same so it
always looks the same
you can't tell if it was a long message
or a short message or if there's a
message or not a message there may not
have been a message it just broadcasts a
[ __ ] 100 character message every day
and you can use what's called a one-time
use pad
to encode to decode that message
but you have to have the pad
or you or you have to know the key
it might be
it's january the first so 12 you know or
one one uh the first page of chapter one
of catcher in the rye is the [ __ ] pad
and what it's doing is giving you
numbers or letters and next to the first
time that letter or number is mentioned
or some there's some kind of key you
have in your mind you'll be able to
point at the letters
based on what's in your head that's why
on that page to know what the code is
and you're given the key verbally
you know
like the book is catcher in the rye
the month is always the chapter
the day the the day's date is always the
page in that chapter
you know what i mean and it goes up to
30.
and that's the page you start on that's
what you're going to use as a one-time
pad so change it every day
see that's why i think that whole
summertime man thing like we did a show
about that um that's why i think that
that [ __ ] was espionage [ __ ] because
they found that book uh the ruby yacht
of omar khayyam yeah it sounds like
something yeah
yeah so i kind of feel like that was
like the key for a lot of messages and
stuff because that seemed like kind of
random because that would just like show
up in someone's car the code book cannot
be a obvious code book you want to be
something that everybody has a new
testament
a certain kind of new testament that
like that nobody would think it was
weird if it wasn't right they find it
and they don't they don't confiscate it
right they're just like okay oh like
everybody's got a bible or everybody's
got a thesaurus or something well
probably not anymore everybody has a
novel
yeah
i wonder if anybody see what if they've
used like some stephen king novels you
see the thing is that the number station
is broadcasting out
and there's more than one agent and each
agent has his own key
so you don't hear the message of the
other agents you only hear the messages
that are intended for you and it might
be that you know well my messages always
come in on thursday
you know
so you're you're the thursday man
or it might be my messages are thursday
at four o'clock
so thursday or fourth year you turn it
on and then you turn it on you wait okay
so
what you're being sent is only good for
your code book it's only for you
no one else can understand that because
they don't have the key they don't have
that book yeah yeah so that's how it's
done
that way you can talk to all your spies
in the field
camp guy said what if the german dude is
a big jd salinger fan
yeah but she wouldn't immediately jump
to
i mean if you're just hearing a big
series of numbers you wouldn't
immediately jump to oh my god that's
he's talking about catcher in the rye
like
chapter whatever page whatever it's like
you wouldn't necessarily jump to that
there's there's a lot of
hoops you have to jump through before
you get to that place where you can like
decode that each spy has his own book he
knows what when to listen to the radio
always it's like i have port noise
complaints i have jude the obscure or i
have right the caster bridge whatever
i'm just going to play and each guy is
on a different day and time
so i'm i'm tuesday 4 a.m you know like
[ __ ] waking me up early for
these messages you know god damn it why
did you get this and you see the number
station is the number station is
constantly putting it out at a regular
time or constantly putting it out that
way the person monitoring the station
the traffic is always the same that way
they cannot match up
radio activity with something happening
in the real world like every time that
[ __ ] radio says something this
[ __ ] leaves his room then you
know it's talking to him you know what i
mean yeah they can't do that so radio
radio traffic is constant yeah they
thought so it's the same
yeah it's called trade craft
okay you have to understand the basics
of trade craft
all that kind of code [ __ ] is like
fascinating to me i love that [ __ ] how
spies do [ __ ] spy [ __ ] spook the spook
world
you know
anything having to do with codes i'm
really into yeah tammy says everybody
has dianetics
i'm sure that's been used as a code at
some point i do not have a copy of
dianetics sadly i should probably get
one but i don't want to pay for it
because if we're walking in [ __ ] dogs
of war his cover his cover to get into
that into what was it nairobi which
which african nation was that he tried
to get they make up an african country i
think they made up yeah his whole code
was to be a [ __ ] bird or whether an
orthopedist what they call him
uh he was a bird ornithologist
ornithologist yeah
that's right yeah it was like birds of
north america
yeah he comes in he says he's a bird
watcher they're not buying it and they
start asking about birds and he knows it
because he [ __ ] studied this [ __ ]
yeah he's like wait you think i wouldn't
do this this is my job yeah they
tortured his ass anyway they didn't
believe him
yeah that african i learned all that
[ __ ] about birds for anything
they tortured my ass anyway yeah that
african intelligence agent knew he says
that's yeah this is [ __ ] this is this
[ __ ] you're not a bird scientist
you're not not with that build i'm just
looking to talk it out yeah you're not a
bird scientist yeah he said he was an
orthologist right yes life you didn't
see dogs of war go see that [ __ ] that
was a [ __ ] old school mercenary movie
kind of cheesy but i still enjoyed it we
saw it recently it was good yeah we just
thought i think we did a matinee on it
yeah yeah yeah it's it's like a i'm
pretty sure they made up an african
nation did they not i don't think it was
a real one no i can't remember no but it
came from a book about mercenaries from
that era from the 60s and it's pretty
accurate it always makes me laugh when
they make up an african nation though
well they made up they made up a central
american age yeah they did for predator
1. they didn't want to say el salvador
they said el giagra didn't they
yeah which is funny because it's like
look i took geography in school it's
like i know that's not there yeah knock
it off yeah
they didn't want to use a real place
because then everybody there would get
mad at them i get it but
it's just funny because it's like
obviously
obviously that's not a real country but
it's like i don't know i just think
that's very funny when they do that
all right so where was i all right um
said nicholas cage no it wasn't nicholas
cage man it was [ __ ] no uh [ __ ]
christopher walken oh in dogs of war
yeah well there might have been more
than one movie called that no
and i think they were talking about and
somebody was talking about there was a
movie about i think it was about the
code talkers yeah that had nicolas cage
in it like from the early 2000s i think
so maybe that's what he's talking about
no i'm talking about i'm talking about
um the one with uh
christopher watching christopher walken
in it that's the one you got to see
it's from
1981 maybe
her late 70s i thought it was late 70s i
thought it was like 78 but i can't
really remember old school [ __ ] man
tammy said i actually found a copy of
dianetics i'm presuming in my uncle's
things when he passed away i haven't
been bored enough to read it yeah that's
bad when people didn't know what
dianetics was they just saw that they
were those are the commercials in the
80s yeah
the big volcano with the volcano that's
where zeno lived yeah yeah where he
destroyed all the things it was like
well yeah they tried to sell it as like
self-help because that was like very big
in the 70s and 80s like buying self-help
books
but even back then i was i didn't know
that was scientology then but even then
i was just kind of like no
self-help
but the weird thing about it is like
it's not self-help
you're not helping yourself you're
buying a book and some other
[ __ ] is trying to help you and
i'm like that's not gonna work for me
i'm sorry that [ __ ] don't know me
but you know all right so uh so where
was that okay so
so yeah so the guys
uh obviously were much faster than the
machines because they had memorized all
the stuff so they gave them like a three
line message and it took them like 20
seconds literally 20 seconds they
transmitted it to their other guy and
that guy like translated it on the other
end and it took 20 seconds and they're
just kind of like okay well this is
amazing it's like way better than the
[ __ ] half an hour the machine took so
they're like okay we're gonna do this
so uh basically they recommend to the
marines well okay you can recruit
uh 200 navajo we're gonna like set up
this little program here
now thank you you talking about
dianetics no oh because you're saying
that it wasn't self-help that was
[ __ ] self-evident no i said no to
help themselves your [ __ ] money well
yeah that's the only thing that's this
yeah
no i said self-help the whole concept of
self-help i'm like you're not really
helping yourself yeah because it's a
book that was written by some
[ __ ] that don't know you right
telling you how to help yourself right i
just i don't think that's self-help
it's some other [ __ ] that don't
know me they're trying to tell me my
life i don't like it
but you know it's you know i i know
other people get [ __ ] out of it but i
don't i don't i don't like being told
like what to do but some [ __ ] that
don't know me so yeah so well i don't
even like being told which is why people
do do know me so you know what i mean
there's that too
so okay so they're gonna do um they're
gonna recruit 200 people
but the first ones they got initially
they started with 30. one of the guys
one guy washed out so they had like 29
and this was the first group
that actually came up with the whole
code
so these first 29 they sent them to boot
camp in may of 1942 uh and then they got
sent to camp pendleton and this is where
they developed the code
what they did
um as i said i kind of feel like in
world war one
what they did was they basically just
translated english messages into
you know choctaw or whatever
um without really like encoding it any
further
but what they did with this one was a
little bit different they added like a
little bit like another layer uh on top
of it
so what they did they kind of modeled it
on uh you had like your the phonetic
alphabet thing where uh you know they
have english words to represent letters
of the alphabet
so they had that um they initially were
gonna do well we're just gonna spell
everything out like using those words
they said no that will take too long so
they're like okay well we'll do that
we'll have the alphabet but then we'll
also have the most commonly used words
and we'll come up with words to encode
uh you know for that like for various
like concepts and you know like planes
and tags [ __ ] like that so they had like
words for all of that
now because as i said navajo didn't have
words for tanks or submarines or
anything like that so they would like
show pictures of various things like you
know
you know [ __ ] destroyer or whatever
and they're like okay what does that
look like to you like
you know come up with something like a
phrase that's memorable to you
and you know translate that into your
language and then we'll translate that
and
code it that way so that's what they did
now the first type of code they created
which was uh this is the type one code
so this was 26
navajo words that stood for
the letters of the alphabet
um and that could be used to spell out a
word if you didn't have another word for
that right
um for example you had the navajo word
for aunt which is uh willachi
and that was uh that was if you wanted
the letter a in english uh you know you
had b was shush which means bear uh c
was moassy that's cat
um and so on now most letters except for
the ones at the end of the alphabet that
nobody uses all that much like z and
[ __ ]
those those unpopular letters most of
letters had also two alternates um you
know for example like b it could be bear
it could be badger it could be like
other things too just to like mix it up
a little so it wasn't like too easy to
figure out
then you had like your type 2 code and
these were words that could be directly
translated from english into navajo now
this ended up being at first it was a
dictionary of about 211 words and then
they expanded it later into 411 and
these were military words and names that
didn't exist in the navajo language uh
prior
so
for example as we mentioned earlier
there was no navajo order for submarine
so they called it bechlow which is iron
fish
which you said before yeah um and then
they would translate iron fish like i
said into navajo which is bachelor
um you know and then they had like the
word for shark which is kalo that was a
destroyer uh a battleship was a whale
that was lotso
uh silver oak leaf uh that was uh che
chill
that was a lieutenant colonel
yeah that's that's what it looks like a
silver leaf yeah that's why they called
it that they just anything that was like
they would they would show them the
concept and they'd be like they try to
come to something they could remember
yeah because they had to memorize all
this they couldn't write it down yeah
because they didn't want anything like
being found yeah gold leaf would have
been a major yeah they had words for
that because like i said i think it's
the navy website because i looked on
there earlier the navy website has the
whole thing like all laid out like in a
chart and you can like look at all the
words and [ __ ] like that they came up
it's like really interesting
um they had names for countries too
which i thought was really interesting
america was nehema which means our
mother
germany was bespeche that means iron hat
yeah
iron helmets yeah iron hat yeah uh a few
of the country names uh hilariously
most of them were pretty neutral couple
of not real pc yeah uh so i thought i
had to mention that
one of them later on
uh one of them was zinni
that means blackies okay that was africa
well that's the kind that's all in
africa yeah all of africa yeah uh and
then guess what they call japan what's
that ben not ali tsotsi what's that
slant eyes slanted people yeah that's
what they call japan those are really
the only two that were kind of like no
the rest of them were pretty like were
pretty neutral you know what i mean like
you know i like floating island i think
was philippines and [ __ ] like that so it
was just like more like what the country
looked like or what it's made where
nature was where where the hell's tila
you know what i was just thinking about
her earlier today i haven't seen her a
long time yeah i don't know like i hope
she's okay yeah tina maybe her schedule
changed or something t if you if you're
out there go ahead and drop something in
the chat line good night and [ __ ] in the
chat
she hasn't she might just be listening i
mean i was thinking about her earlier
yeah today and i was just kind of like
man she was getting ready to move
wouldn't she oh maybe that's what it was
trying to get out of they were trying to
get out of san francisco maybe she moved
and like
maybe her schedule changed or some [ __ ]
like that might be in the middle of a
move or she's kind of in the middle of
because yeah
they were even talking about leaving a
state
okay so maybe they're going through some
[ __ ] right now and sandra never saw
sandra again yeah she's been gone a long
time german's got her
the champion's guy yeah the germans got
her she died of a peanut butter overdose
yeah
peanut butter in germany got her peanut
butter in germany yeah
peanut butter
yeah i wonder where i went she went to
flip that german girl over to eating
peanut butter she's like oh yeah peanut
butter is good and then all she did she
couldn't stop eating peanut butter
then she had peanut butter everything
she was asking what brands to get
because tell you guys something
if you're from
america north america when you think of
peanut butter there's a certain product
that comes to your mind a certain taste
that comes to your mind europeans don't
have that particular taste in mind when
their peanut butter [ __ ] sucks sucks
ass british peanut butter if it's a
british brand sucked so they don't like
it
but if you say no get peter pan get
skippy or jiff or jiff and smooth or
crunchy of any of those crunchy crunchy
good
i'm a crunchy girl smooth's good too
right i won't i won't say no to that
they're both good but i prefer crunchy
and then they don't know what to do with
it you put that [ __ ] on toast
butter both sides of the toast yep and
then put [ __ ] grape what we call
jelly but you guys call it preserves or
jam
some kind of jam i like grape jam
strawberry is good too strawberry's good
too on one piece of bread and then the
peanut butter on the other and you put
them together like that or peanut butter
and honey is also very good yeah but it
need it it's okay
it doesn't it doesn't have a fruit
flavor to it though that's true i showed
that german girl that she came back she
says oh hell yeah
because that's what we're talking about
see that's why we like people that's why
americans
you see because we have good peanut
butter and our history the history of
our country
had had
mars and had [ __ ] hershey's chocolate
and one of the first big candies the
number one candy is a [ __ ] reese's
peanut butter cup
oh
which is weird because that's like some
gritty ass peanut butter in there but it
works
it works with the with the whole gestalt
i was in boston and went to went went to
[ __ ] uh harvard square
back in the 90s
it was the mid 90s and they had a candy
shop there making candy
and this is [ __ ] it would rival
anything in europe they're making their
own chocolates and making their own
candy bars
and they had peanut butter cups in there
about six different flavors of them the
size of a [ __ ] apple that's how big
they were they were like that big and
about that [ __ ] tall
they were about three or five bucks
back in the 90s
man those things were good and they had
all different combinations
like peanut butter
and jelly grape jelly in white chocolate
that was one of the ones that they see
i'm a big fan of like white chocolate
with peanut butter inside that shit's
delicious i mean i love white chocolate
and they had the regular milk chocolate
with peanut butter and then they had all
the different variations and swirls and
[ __ ]
white and white chocolate and milk
chocolate swirled together with peanut
butter in the middle then it was huge
man and and
you'd get three quarters of the way
through it you're like
damn i don't know if i can eat this
anymore this [ __ ] is getting so rich
yeah i don't think i could eat a whole
lot i was like and i was walking around
trying to eat it i was thinking man i
need some milk
you know
milk would have helped but i did
eventually eat them
but the first [ __ ] going through that
eating half of it was like eating four
reese's peanut butter cup packages it's
like eating that so it's like eating
eight of them there's the [ __ ] man i
don't know if that candy shop still
there
zach says a few scoops of peanut butter
goes great on mint chocolate chip ice
cream oh yeah probably you know what i
don't think i mean i've had peanut
butter on vanilla ice cream yeah and
that's delicious yeah it's good
ice cream i don't think i've ever yeah
it's good on chocolate ice cream too but
i don't think i've ever had it on mint
chocolate chips that probably would be
good actually yeah because mint
chocolate chip is actually one of my
favorite flavors yeah all right let's
get back to the show all right good
we're going to go down a sideways path
of fighting food and [ __ ] okay well yeah
all right whose fault is that
whose fault is that yeah peanut butter
cups and ice cream hell yeah yeah yeah
they do yeah i mean
well there's a reason that dairy queen
sells those blizzard things you have
like the the peanut butter cups yeah
in the in the peanut butter fudge
yeah i told you my mom used to make like
[ __ ] fantastic peanut butter fudge we
should probably make some yeah i could
make some we probably have like a [ __ ]
ton of peanut butter in this in this
house or peanut butter in this house i
mean
uh so yeah so
like i said the navy website has a whole
like uh dictionary like all the terms
and stuff they came up with and all the
words they came up with like for all the
letters and stuff like that so it's
really like interesting so they did
actually develop a code book you weren't
allowed to like take it anyplace
obviously because if anybody found it
they would be [ __ ] but they had to
you know they had to write it down at
some point because they had to teach it
to people because like i said the
original 29 the people that came up with
the code
once they came up with it they had to
like write it all down so they could you
know when new guys came in they had to
like show them how to do it before they
uh were deployed so there was that
um so they never took it out in the
field they just like kept it in the
classroom
now as i said
when they were out in the field
obviously they were they could not write
anything down they just had to memorize
the message
and then translate it and then put it
over the radio so no one could write
anything down because nobody wanted
anything to be found
now as i mentioned earlier because they
had all of this code [ __ ]
and another it wasn't just them
translating an english message just
directly into navajo they had all these
other like a layer or two on top of it
so even if someone that spoke navajo
heard the message
they wouldn't understand
what it was saying because it would just
sound like gibberish or like a garbled
like it wouldn't make any sense to them
like they might understand some of the
words but they wouldn't understand what
the word signified you know what i mean
because that's you know they had like
different terms to mean different like
military things and if you didn't know
what that was then you wouldn't know
they're like why are they talking about
leaves i don't get it i'm gonna turn
that fan off oh [ __ ] oh
well you have to have this [ __ ] is it
the center one yeah well i had to turn
the light on the other day because i was
making a um video all right
gotta get some his fan action because
i've been drinking and i'm starting to
get hot under here today was an
injection day took all my injections so
i'm like
you got all kind of problems oh yeah i
know
my manliness is [ __ ] going fourfold
right now is it no it is
i don't know it's all that melee you're
always kind of like oh i've had the
vapors or whatever it is you're doing
okay
i just gotta get behind
you'll be all right
uh yeah now uh it should be
said too that a lot of the code talkers
they weren't just dudes that you know
talked into the radio or the phone or
whatever
um they had to know how to like uh
they carried all the equipment obviously
which like you said was very heavy back
in those days uh they had to know how to
operate like all the radio equipment and
the you know the wire equipment they had
to carry it on their backs they had to
set it all up and like the electronic
lines and everything like that
um they also had to know how to fight
and a lot of them actually went into
combat um and there was a thing too like
especially when
the code talker program was new
and
knowledge of their existence wasn't
widespread like a lot of times they
would show up at like some battle or
whatever and they're just like yeah get
out there like in the front lines or
they would like
employ them like doing messages and
stuff like that because they didn't know
that they were
doing the code thing you know what i
mean so a lot of them actually did
actually uh see combat like i said so
yeah so that's what they would do they
would be given the message in english
they wouldn't write it down translate it
and then they would send it to their
team member the other code talker the
other uh navajo and then they would
write the message down in english and
then they'd put it in the logbook
yeah now let me let me go ahead and say
something here you know most navajo of
this era
weren't big guys either okay you're
talking five between five three to five
seven five seven probably would have
been a pretty big
navajo at that time i've seen
photographs of them
and uh some of the native americans that
that i served with also the smaller guys
but it's weird sometimes they'll be
small and then you have some
six foot one dude you know [ __ ] not
all native americans were the same size
they had good genetic diversity zamora
sergeant zamora he was much bigger than
his dad from what i've seen in the
videos of him talking to the feds over
that damn ufo [ __ ] sergeant zamora was
probably six one big dude
big dude he was kind of like sunny from
[ __ ] predator one he was like that
yeah
remember that dude sonny yeah yeah
mr idiot said tom is having hot flashes
yeah exactly
are you going through menopause no it's
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm going to
inject
well that's right
it's good though it feels good it's all
coming back and going through my hormone
therapy people
yeah i'm going through the heavier part
of my cycle
your menstrual
cycle
cycle your menstrual cycle
yeah we need to we need to popularize
that concept
trying to gain a few more pounds and
lose some weight
lose some fat around the waist and
[ __ ] gain a few more pounds i want to
gain about another 10 pounds upper body
but it's going to take time to do it
safely i've been [ __ ] working out
[ __ ] hard lifting heavy uh i'm on the
right [ __ ] too so we'll see
it's gonna be good
sure
oh jenny knows i love it
yeah you do i love it he said like i
said his gym is right next to my office
right here i always hear him and they're
going but
when i'm trying to work i'm just like oh
geez i feel so good
[Laughter]
it's fun
yeah
i need to work out partner
well you better go find one then see
okay all right go ahead out all right
now i don't told you that a million
times
it's not fun for me
uh so yeah so okay give me a female
workout partner she'll be in there
lickety-split working out and trying to
push that girl out how much you want to
bet no i want to you wouldn't no okay
i'm gonna give me a few more workout
partners now okay my partner my charger
too yeah i need to get it i need a
student
yeah get some money i need yeah i need a
student get some money
trying these [ __ ] don't want to work
out
you know maybe they just don't want to
work out with me that's what it is
[Laughter]
is that a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
zach says well it is called menopause
not meno keep going
that was pretty good with that who said
that [ __ ] zack [ __ ] sad
zach he's he he's big into menology
manism he's studying man
menology
okay this is hilarious all right
so uh so yeah so we were talking about
the battle of iwo jima earlier which
very very famous battle um
so on iwo jima they actually had six
navajo code talkers and they worked in
shifts
24 hours a day
uh and they
you know pretty much during the first
two days of the battle they relayed like
some very very important messages uh 800
messages actually uh during those two
days
and
those 800 messages had not a single
mistake
and uh for that reason because they
conveyed all that information like
during this battle because we were
talking earlier about how
[ __ ] up that battle was it was like
like i said it's on like a little bitty
island and the japanese were there to
like we're gonna wipe out everybody or
die in the effort and
so it was kind of like a [ __ ] show
um
but yeah so the fact that they
sent or received 800 messages without
making a single mistake um
basically one of the
majors
who was uh you know kind of
in charge of the [ __ ] at the time
his quote was were it not for the
navajos the marines would never have
taken iwo jima because they
conveyed so much important information
uh and the codes were not cracked
so
you know again
uh but it wasn't all fun and games like
i said
it wasn't fun and games at all
there were times where some of the
navajo code talkers were mistaken for
japanese and were captured by other
american soldiers and they had to sort
it out and uh can you imagine
at some point it's like a couple of them
they said that i guess looked more
japanese or whatever they had to give
them bodyguards yeah to let to protect
them from the other americans okay look
i'm gonna look i've been american please
do not
capture me let me give some historical
cultural context though with this okay
you're talking about a time
before there was a global mass media
japan was something these dudes had only
maybe had seen in a national geographic
magazine they didn't know what a
japanese person looked like not really
they probably weren't even sure what
would an indian look like depending on
where they came from no probably not so
unless you're from the southwest yeah
unless you're from the southwest so
to see a person who is non-white
with black hair and light skin in that
uniform you might think that might be
the japanese
that's exactly what they would think
so it would take a while to straighten
that out but no but yeah some of them
that didn't know about the code talker
program also thought that when they
heard them over the radio that they
might have been japanese talking because
it sounded to them just sounded like a
foreign language that they didn't
understand so it's like japanese the
japanese must have taken
so
so yeah so they had some issues with uh
with that
so uh basically so what they did okay so
it works like a really good you know it
worked really good for her time and then
what they would have to do is they would
go to like uh you know meetings and
stuff in hawaii where they would kind of
like codify the code book and make sure
everybody's on the same page and all
that kind of [ __ ] um and then they had
to like train other code talkers so
everybody like knew the same code words
and [ __ ] like that
um and honestly this
using navajo code talkers uh they used
it in the korean war also
um
and it was and it a little bit into the
vietnam war although it was ended like
kind of early in that conflict but they
so they used it in other wars other than
like world war one and world war ii they
did actually use it later on but like i
said his technology kind of progressed
and that he probably didn't need it as
much and maybe people were like more
familiar with it too although i have to
say
that
interestingly they it wasn't really uh
widely known by
society as a whole um
this program was actually not known at
all until like the late 1960s
so
basically like when i was watching the
documentary like some of the code
talkers that had been like of the
original 29 that were still alive
they came out and said yeah well you
know we came back and
they didn't really even get any
accolades or any kind of like promotions
or nothing it's just kind of everybody
was like well thanks you did a good job
it's like you saved our butts and
everything like that but it's like they
didn't really
get much of anything out of it and it's
like nobody
even knew that they had done that until
like the late 1960s because the thing
about it was that they kind of wanted to
keep it a secret
in case they wanted to use it again so
they didn't want to become to become
wide knowledge it's like oh we're using
like you know navajo or we're using
whatever like native american language
uh to encode messages they didn't want
really that being common knowledge like
you know the military so
they were kind of like i don't know if
they like
if they told the code talkers hey don't
tell anybody about it but they were kind
of like well we were kind of encouraged
like not to talk too much about it just
in case they wanted to use that [ __ ]
again so you know they they felt like
they shouldn't really like talk about it
too widely
uh so as i mentioned earlier the navajo
code the one they came up with for the
original 29 only spoken military code
never to be deciphered by the enemy
never that's the only one that was never
deciphered uh i have to say too uh just
as as an aside
also in world war ii the canadian armed
forces also employed like uh first
nation soldiers uh who spoke the cree
language uh as code talkers now
they also didn't really get any
recognition
either uh because the [ __ ] was
classified until i believe in 1963
and so they were not acknowledged
uh so yeah so the code talkers didn't
get any recognition until 1968 uh their
operation was declassified in that year
it wasn't however until 1982 when the
code talkers were actually given a
certificate of recognition by ronald
reagan uh and they had a navajo code
talkers day which was august 14th 1982
so that was kind of like something to do
then in december of 2000
uh bill clinton signed a law which
awarded the congressional gold medal to
the original 29 like the guys that had
come up with the original code
and uh they also got so those guys got
gold medals and then they got silver
medals like if you were a part of the
kotaka program but the original 29 that
had come up with the code got gold
medals so they got those
and um but like i said the last of the
original 29 uh who developed the code
died in uh 2014.
let me go ahead and say
well there's one more sentence let me
say one more sentence
i didn't know this
but there's actually a code talkers
monument
in ocala florida okay which is where my
mom lives and it's actually it's only
like an hour from here which i didn't
even know that but yeah there's a ocala
florida memorial park and there is a
code talkers monument right there with
all their names on it which i thought
was like kind of cool now the code
talker thing was secret but there was a
lot of other secret [ __ ] that involved
native americans and other people all
right
because
the native american angle
and secrecy kind of
went went hand in hand okay for a while
a lot of people don't know this but this
is something that i gleaned from reading
other things from other books later on
you had native americans also in the
skunk works lockheed martin skunk works
which is what they were doing all the
top secret [ __ ] out there in groom lake
like the sr-71 and atomic bomb programs
and all this [ __ ]
guys that kind of have a tribal
background
weren't in the mainstream of society and
they were honorable they could keep
their [ __ ] mouth shut and a lot of
those programs that was happening in in
in inside lockheed martin the skunk
works and all that area 51 type [ __ ] was
cash jobs
so there was no there were contractors
and they were paid in cash that way
there was no um
[ __ ] paper trail you know what i mean
and all this stuff is getting getting
paid out of black budgets
and what they did is they helped run
ranges and
maintain buildings and
drivers and
people that would [ __ ] work and in in
those on those camps
and they kept their [ __ ] mouth shut
not only then but uh
ex
ex [ __ ] italian gangsters and
criminals and [ __ ]
working out there on those weird
clandestine
cia funded programs so that's just the
kind of on the sideline you know this
isn't the only thing native americans
were doing they did a lot of [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] well like i said a lot of
them served in the military yeah so
certain the military and into all kinds
of things they were of the right profile
that where
you could work with them and word would
never get out
strong 78 said there was one native
american dude a wire man in my artillery
battery super quiet and could lift all
the heavy equipment like it was nothing
yeah yeah
um
mr88 said reagan gave the code talkers
recognition to atone for his awful b
westerns
yeah b western's [ __ ] sucked uh
probably so i'm saying maybe he felt bad
i don't really that's that's a debt
that's a debt we owe to the italians
though because uh the italians showed us
how to make western movies [ __ ]
sergio leone and [ __ ]
some of the spaghetti westerns were so
good that we had to [ __ ] revamp the
[ __ ] which is hilarious that it took
like italians to be like look you can't
even make [ __ ] movies about your own
goddamn country here yeah here this is
what and we're like oh right yeah you're
right and clint eastwood who was in some
of the [ __ ] best [ __ ] spaghetti
westerns started his own production
company in a lot of the great westerns
[ __ ] weird clint clint you know like
[ __ ] outlaw josie wales and [ __ ]
pale rider and [ __ ] unforgiven and
[ __ ] man [ __ ]
high planes drifter
those are actually copies of italian
movies that's italian
italian spaghetti which is hilarious to
me because i kind of feel like for a
long time it felt like well a lot of
people perceived
that like a lot of italian entertainment
was just like ripping off
american movies
which they do yeah
but
the thing about it is that well
particularly with westerns and
particularly in horror movies because
like i said the slasher movies
are essentially like a ripoff of italian
jalo movies
so
which i mean to be fair could be
constituted as like a ripoff of like
alfred hitchcock movies maybe but it's
like i don't know it's it's more like a
back and forth yes the italians did make
a lot of shitty knockoffs of you know
like when jaws came out they made like
the last shark and [ __ ] like that that
was obviously like jaws but much
shittier
but yeah they did that but they also did
like a lot of really good [ __ ] too
so [ __ ] what sergio did sergio showed
americans
that they showed us that that the
western
is one it is gothic
two it is post-apocalyptic
and three it is important
and that's what [ __ ] sergio gave
that's what that was the angle he came
out
what made
what made the western movie so important
and what made the western story
important was that [ __ ] soundtrack go
listen to [ __ ] the soundtrack to good
and bad the ugly or any sergio leone
movies
and and uh sergio leone westerns and the
movies just sound [ __ ] important they
just sound epic as [ __ ]
well italy has a long tradition of like
opera yeah yeah and drama yeah like that
so they know like heightened they don't
have to do that right they're into that
and all those [ __ ] crosses and
[ __ ] burnt down buildings and this is
a mad max western you know
and that's how frontier khanna was in a
certain way a town would spring up and
then be destroyed and even in the 1800s
when there were [ __ ] outlaws and [ __ ]
going on
it was still kind of post-apocalyptic
because there was stuff going on there
in the 1700s that was still ruins you
know what i mean so
and you're kind of in a gray area
legally you know it's kind of like being
on the high seas in the age of piracy
it's like that but it's on land
so
sergio leone you knew how to tell that
story
one of these days i still want to do a
florida pirates show yeah
when i was in st augustine i bought um
the book under the black flag which i
still haven't read yet which is all
about pirates but yeah florida has a
long tradition of like pirate [ __ ] yeah
and i'm like i really like all the south
is steeped in culture and it's just
so many different cultures we're here
florida is very piratey well especially
like tampa yeah like tampa area is all
[ __ ] piratey yeah it was all kind of
like pirate [ __ ] going over there it's
like pirate rex there's all kind of
stuff they even have like a [ __ ]
festival every year called gasparilla
which is all like it's like mardi gras
but pirate yeah it's
the south is
indian
it's mexican
it's irish
it's
african
especially talking about new orleans
it's french
and it's spanish
all happening in the same place it's
like some [ __ ] out of a [ __ ] pirates
of the caribbean or the caribbean and
it's like something out of a dam yeah
it's just
and it
it the south has a real good story good
heritage behind it and it's uh it is
kind of what me and jenny because it is
gothic
it has a gothic flavor to it
you know
even anne rice knew that
you know
spanish well that's why there's a whole
there's a whole southern gothic
sub genre right then there has been for
a very long time
yeah which has a very specific wall here
you know set of troops yeah camp guys
said they're still digging up spanish
treasure ships in florida i love
treasure stuff yeah i mean honestly you
should seriously go to tampa um or go to
st augustine because
saint augustine is
spanish stuff native american stuff and
pirate stuff that's pretty much like all
it is there's a pirate museum there
which is
small but it's like it's pretty [ __ ]
epic they have like all kind of stuff
like that they've dug up from
you know from wrecks like right there
like right in right in the atlantic
ocean which is saint augustine is on the
atlantic ocean in case you didn't know
but all stuff that they found like right
there so it's like it's really really
cool
but yeah it's just it's it's super super
fun
but yeah if you're into that kind of
stuff like come to florida there's
i don't know we talk about this a lot
florida is the south
but
it's kind of a it's kind of like an
amalgam it's a different blend of the
south of lots of different things it's
the south and central america at the
same time
it's the south and
and nicaragua
or cuba well cuba really isn't so much
the south cuba is more like spain you
know it's just a mixture of a bunch of
stuff
and it's been here for centuries
and outsiders didn't don't know this
culture you know that's why back
when me and sly were boys back in the
70s and the 80s the south had its own
movies you know [ __ ] it released its
own movies you know a lot of it was
[ __ ] you know she was like malone
most of them had bert reynolds burt
reynolds
[Laughter]
had his own these you had movies that
were released just for the south and it
is its own culture
um but even that i mean i grew up here
and the thing about it is that florida
has a lot of that like it has a lot of
the very southern like what people call
like rednecky kind of stuff yeah but
then there's like it depends on where
you go though yeah it's not everything
that's like some that's like the
panhandle that's like some parts of
central florida but
tennessee mississippi not everywhere is
like that not everywhere it's like that
like there are african parts of
mississippi that are almost kind of like
haiti
same thing with with louisiana you know
around the port areas kind of like haiti
uh
and then you have spanish areas
there's a lot of span there's a lot of
spanish implants in florida as well
obviously yeah because and you know my i
have spanish and french names you know
in my family my grandfather's name was
bolivar his name was boliver ross my
middle name is francis yeah [ __ ] the
[ __ ] [ __ ] of that thing like that
[ __ ] zack man is am i gay for having
that middle names act do you tell me he
doesn't tell a lot of people
i got there's french names and there's
spanish names you know in my family
um
and it's just because it was the french
the spanish the irish and africans
and mexicans and indians
all in the same area
yeah
yeah
kind of like all of this kind of but
like i said and it was across the board
you had desert over in the [ __ ]
uh over in like the california new
mexico utah area and arizona it's all
desert and then it starts going into
texas which is park desert park
grassland and then you start going
tropical and tropical france like
something out of them
vietnam when you start getting into
louisiana mississippi it's like it's
like the mekong delta it's also in in
alabama in the panhandle and then you
start going into florida it's more like
honduras nicaragua salvador you know
it's like that it's a swamp it's a swamp
i mean and the thing about it is that
and i think we brought this up before
like central and south florida
used to be a swamp yeah uh before disney
came and before legging they started
building on it and like people started
moving down here because like the
weather was nice or like warmer i guess
uh some people started moving down here
god knows why but um
yeah so they built over the swamp south
florida is still a swamp largely other
than like miami and the [ __ ] on the
coasts the middle part of south florida
that's all swamp right and here's
something else you know the south part
of mississippi the south part of of
florida is central america basically
genetically
and just it's the type and and and and
the weather it's like nicaragua and in
the 80s it was a full-on [ __ ] drug
cartel war there and it was not a joke
no joke at all
you got people from new york moving down
there and it's they like it but it's
culture shock that is there it is that
is nothing like new york nothing but the
thing about it now is that totally
different and especially nowadays
because i kind of feel like and even
when i was young and i was born in
florida i was born in daytona beach
um
even back then it was starting to change
you had a lot of like you still like
southern cracker type [ __ ] and like you
had all the swamp people and all that
kind of stuff but
there was still loads and loads of
people that had moved from up north or
had vacation homes down here there were
snow birds uh because of the weather
they would come down here in the winter
but i kind of feel like that's
accelerated it's the thing about it even
when i was in high school i was one of
only two people that i knew in my whole
high school
that had been born in florida my best
friend was born in gainesville yeah and
everyone else was born someplace else
yeah a lot of them in other places in
the south though
not necessarily a lot of them were new
yorkers a lot of people from illinois
ohio for whatever reason i knew a lot of
people that were from there
um well i've lived all over this place
and i can look at the demographics and i
can look at how the culture is going in
politics they move here and they are not
changing this place this place is
changing them
there's no the people that i meet in
florida on a daily basis are only con
the only the kind of people you would
meet in florida
they're not
yeah some of them do have influences
from up north but this this is still
the south i mean i [ __ ] lived in the
north lived in boston the northeast of
the north i was there for five years and
enjoyed it
but that and and and also up in uh the
michigan area for i think two years
and uh part of that one year that was in
detroit and the which is that you know
that's where my actual foley [ __ ] man
crush came from but looking there's
nothing this place is nothing like the
north nothing this place is nothing like
anywhere yeah it's its own thing because
well and the thing about it like i said
you don't really have
and i think even less so than when i was
a kid
um you don't have a lot of people that
were born here anymore
most people come here from other places
it's to me it's herb it's it's kind of
so it's like an amalgam of like every to
me it's kind of like an urban more
sophisticated south
there's a difference between mississippi
deep mississippi south and say florida
south there's a big difference there
yeah um so when i say south
i'm talking about south in general
it's not the same in mississippi you
come back to heidelberg with me
oh no it's a whole different [ __ ]
planet okay different [ __ ] planet
there is [ __ ] that people will do in an
urban environment here in in say orlando
that would never fly never fly
in deep mississippi
i mean orlando is pretty
i don't want to say it's like super
cosmopolitan because it's just more
sophisticated it's not in terms of like
bigger cities but
i mean it's
a bigger city i've been to florida i've
been to the biggest [ __ ] cities in
the [ __ ] world one of them was
[ __ ] sao paulo brazil i partially
grew up there and this is nothing like
that even though i love brazil
but i like brazil i like sao paulo much
better than boston or new york it's a
lot more free and open even though
that's like mad max world i [ __ ] love
the third world you guys are calling it
third world my friends call it the third
one
most of the girls i grew up with in
brazil live here in florida now
okay because
they just evacuate all the pretty girls
out of brazil to get them up here to the
united states and they're all living
here
this is a south america south flavor it
just is
i've been to south america been in
brazil it is like central or south
america it is it does have that yeah it
does have a very strong variety of that
it is in part half of it is like central
or south america the other half of it is
kind of like the south like with mud
trucks
harleys guns nascar nascar
it's a mixture of that and they're
interbreeding
so there isn't a conflict between the
two cultures they're just like yeah okay
whatever they don't care they're they're
all having a good time
and um
like the biker bar that i go to all the
time
if you look at those people the [ __ ]
half of them are latino
but they've just been here for
generations
it's
i i just like the place it's fun
it's got a future i like how it goes it
reminds me a lot of when i was a kid it
reminds me of uh
the way
san diego and vista california were back
in the 70s
it felt kind of like this
which was a good good place fun get a
lot for your money
outside of a city
but you have access to a city
drive 30 minutes down these new tall
roads me and jenny be downtown
having a good time
linwood lynnwood sly says visited
orlando back in the 90s brought a
surfboard but never went surfing well
you can't surf in orlando yeah surf in
orlando it's uh it's in the central but
did you not know that like the ocean is
like an hour hour and a half away yeah
yeah yeah depending on where you are in
orlando like i said i i was born in
daytona beach which is right on the
ocean yeah so it's surfing good in
daytona probably not huh not really no i
mean people do surf there like i have uh
uncles and cousins and stuff like that
that are super into it but to be honest
with you
okay i'm gonna say there's a reason why
every time a hurricane is coming all the
surfers get excited yeah and they go out
there to the beach
uh you know against all uh
advisements
um they're like [ __ ] it we're gonna go
out there and get some because daytona
like the beach is not unless it's really
windy the waves are pretty small gonna
say it's not great surfing you can surf
but it's not like california or
australia or some like great surfing
place like it's possible but
i don't know i used to go to the beach a
lot as a kid not because i necessarily
wanted to but because my mom was really
into it because i'm not really a beach
person
but
yeah the surfing's not fantastic but you
totally cannot surf in orlando we got
lots of lakes in orlando but if you want
to go to the ocean you got to drive at
least an hour
like uh to the east or to the west i'm
gonna say
if you just want a beach like a
beautiful beach
generally
the west coast of florida tampa
clearwater um the beaches are nicer
nicer looking
um but that's the gulf of mexico so i
don't really know i don't think the
surfing is much better over there
uh you know daytona saint augustine
chill like that's the atlantic ocean
you're probably better or better off
surfing over there but still not great
serving i i do know people that surf
there but it's not fantastic so i said
cletus clint eastwood's western
soundtracks i studied in college in
indian hills community college here in
iowa 1978. yeah you're talking about
you're talking about uh the uh the ones
with sergio leone he was he directed him
real good today's twenties and thirties
never seen a good western that's right
yeah young people have never seen a good
western movie probably
well
there have been some good ones like here
and there it's just not really like a
big genre well what they did was is that
they played that [ __ ] some western
video games they're supposed to be
really good like what is it dead red red
dead redemption yeah everybody says it's
great i've never played it
but uh
one of the guys i subscribed to who's
big into
movies and entertainment says that now
is the time for some badass westerns
and
yeah
yeah a couple of bad some bad ass
westerns probably would be really good
i mean i feel like some people have been
like ty west made one like back in 2016.
like some people have been making them
yeah it's just
it's not like ubiquitous like it used to
be you know i mean like where there was
all kind of westerns but i have seen
some good ones like in the last few
years so they're still around
yeah
yeah let me see why says thomas reynolds
was comical and honest in tv no yeah
[ __ ]
no uh yeah uh [ __ ] uh reynolds was
good good dude he's a good dude i really
recommend for a while they were showing
it for free what was it gator
yeah and what was the second part of
gator
it was gator with the first weightlifter
the first one was white lightning and
then the second one was
yeah
[ __ ] gator was his name go see white
lightning and gator those are some white
exploitation movies man [ __ ] from the
south crackers cracker exploitation it
was kind of like on a position
yeah it was almost kind of like it was
almost kind of like petey wii straw of
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] what was his name [ __ ] uh
radio anymore yeah rudy ray moore they
were kind of like rudy they were higher
budgets than rudy ray moore
and you know rudy wasn't working with a
whole lot it's just most people
volunteering i like his movies jenny
almost bought me the whole collection
already more we saw we were in fye and
they had the whole reading rate for like
all of his movies in one box it was like
a hundred dollars though i get that [ __ ]
online for cheaper than that but well
you can some of them are on to be like
petey wheatstraw the devil's son-in-law
yeah
that's all on tv yeah and [ __ ] he he
inspired uh eddie you know from eddie
murphy but uh no
go check out [ __ ] white lightning and
gator
yeah we were playing it for free
those movies were actually mostly made
for tennessee
they said that they
just opening night in nashville they'd
break even everything else was great
because everybody goes they were just
made just for the south and they were
good movies they were good movies
they were like southern
gangster
action adventure ex-con he's kind of
like the [ __ ] southern
james bond because you know because
there's never going to be a james bond
for the south
the only way you're going to be james
bond in the south is be an ex-con and of
course of course [ __ ] he's an ex-con
you know just they're just good movies
camp guy says kelly slater world
champion surfer 15 years plus from cocoa
beach florida cocoa beach is about
an hour south of where i grew up yeah
maybe the surfing is better down there i
mean it's okay in daytona i'm not saying
that but like i said there is a reason
why when a hurricane's coming all the
surfers get excited to run out there
because it's like better than usual you
know what i mean yeah even though like
all the people like get off the beach
you're gonna get [ __ ] up hey sly said
tomahawk was good
all right sli i'm gonna break it to you
right here on the show my friend made
that movie brian hackett and he's on
he's in the comments section every now
and then he turned it yeah we went to
military school together out in
california
for a while but he he did the sound for
that movie
he also did the sound for the movie uh
um [ __ ] vfw which is another [ __ ]
good good movie man vfw was yeah not a
western but not a west it was a horror
movie
kind of like a survival horror i guess
yeah you would call it
but yeah that was good what was the most
is brian
i don't know
he shows up in here every now and then
okay what was the most uh recent great
western the last western i can think of
at all was the hateful eight
um like i said uh i'm pretty sure ty
west who usually makes horror movies
obviously he made house of the devil and
x and stuff like that he made one but
that was back in 2016. i can't remember
the name of it um
i'm trying to think
what was that one
this might have been like earlier than
the hatefully though what was that one
the proposition
that like nick cave wrote the screenplay
that one was pretty awesome yeah straw
dogs brian also did terror on the
prairie
i haven't seen it yet though
yeah we haven't seen it he said he's
gonna send me a free code to watch it on
on release date yeah we'll see it
it has my girl on it man
oh what's her name [ __ ] uh
that girl was cute man
mma fighter
what's her name gina corona gina carano
yeah she was cute
how come i remember stuff when i'm drunk
because no i'm drunk and i had those i'm
trying to do i gotta go look look okay
do you want me to make another drink uh
sure okay
uh linwood says i've seen them tom white
lightning and even his last two movies
yeah what'd you think of white lightning
what are you going to stand there
[Laughter]
little slide said i loved hatefully yeah
hatefully was actually really good
uh even saw elvis movies because he
inspired me to talk with hot
women i kind of i love the elvis movies
um you know he wasn't like a fantastic
actor but he was just like so
charismatic so what are you guys like uh
i kind of want to see
i don't know if you guys know but
baslerman
an elvis movie which i think is coming
out in a week or two
and i kind of want to see it it looks
kind of awesome i mean you know
i like i like moulin rouge
he made that romeo and juliet movie that
tom loves so we'll probably go see that
elvis thing
uh last question i can think of that
made of mark was unforgiven yeah that
was actually really good too there have
been some like
here and there but i kind of feel like
they haven't
i don't know
i was gonna say no country for old men
but
that's not technically a western is it
that's kind of i mean
it's sort of like a western
but
there will be blood oh yeah that was a
good one i saw that in the theater
actually that was kind of like a western
yeah that was good
i only saw it once though i wouldn't
mind like re-watching it i saw that in
the theater
i'm not like real big into westerns like
oh what like i said i'm not averse to
pretty much any uh film genre if it's
good i'll watch it i don't give a [ __ ]
what it is um
but there are some obviously like i'm a
horror person so it's like i'm always
gonna see those first and the other ones
i'm just kind of like okay maybe i'll
see it if everybody says it's good but
i don't usually seek them out so
westerns i don't usually like seek them
out until everybody says oh my god
that's the best thing ever you have to
see it then
yeah and tammy brings up bone tomahawk
yeah i mean bone tomahawk was epic
which and it was largely a western i
mean toward the end it was uh went into
horror movie territory but yeah
lindsay says uh i hope the elvis movie
is good it's just a commercial yeah i
mean i saw the trailer
and i don't know it looks cool and like
i said i like baslerman's other movies i
love moulin rouge um so
if it's like that then i'll be into it
probably and i like elvis so
i i don't see how it could be that bad
right
i was talking about that new elvis movie
that's coming in yeah yeah that is what
is that coming out
it should be uh we saw the poster for it
did you where's my drink at oh [ __ ] oh
really
oh
i thought you just made the drink it
just like left it sitting there
oh my god
tommy need to get your [ __ ] together
get your [ __ ] together
yeah we also gotta see uh we just gotta
see top gun yeah we still got to see top
gun i wanted to see um wow there's kind
of a lot of top gun and elvis go see
them both i'm going to see top gun or
see elvis we'll go see those tomorrow
um
because we're done working tomorrow
that's true i'm gonna see you tomorrow
um
i wanted to see
men that knew a24 movie and
whenever the new jordan peel comes out
which is called nope nope but i think
that looks [ __ ] good but
i don't think that comes out until the
end of the month hold on let me go put
mice in this and i also want to see
black phone i think that starts next
week too
like end of june
that's the new blumhouse
with uh ethan hawk in it that looks good
so
it sucks man it's like
we moved out here and
the movie theater
by our old house is still the closest
one to this so now
huh we're done with code talkers yeah
okay good
making sure so the main the main uh
yeah i covered everything okay main
thing's covered so i'm just i'm saying
that out loud now so i don't like wake
up in the middle and i'd be like oh [ __ ]
i forgot we got the damn cookie butter i
know
we need i need to put this on some toast
so we can finish that up but that's just
going to sit there you what are you
putting in there cookies
i'm not putting anything in there every
now and then i'll put a spoon in there
and like just eat some off a spoon all
right we're going to make a sandwich
with that
zachary says jenny
sly said jenny my dad's like tom's dad
grew up with with westerns with wester's
i guess sorry yeah my grandpa did yeah
my dad seemed like my dad seemed like he
wasn't really all that into movies
he was more a music guy sly's wanting to
see elvis too look man it looks good
that's my people okay he he just his
family's just from tupelo just a little
bit maybe like
90 miles from where my family's from
that's a nick cave song yeah it's called
tupelo it's about it's about elvis's
elvis being born yeah nothing is twin
dying and he moved over to the nashville
area after that
but uh no i'm fascinated by elvis
actually sly if you want to see a good
elvis movie see elvis and nixon
that's good yeah it's a good movie that
was about elvis's secret mission to talk
his way into the white house go see the
[ __ ] president
nixon and eat all his m m's to eat his
eminence
and to become a [ __ ] undercover
special narcotics agent sure this [ __ ]
is [ __ ] hilarious he wanted a badge
yeah
we don't know what he wants we don't
know what he wanted
but that movie right there uh it was
checked out the
checked out by elvis's friends who were
there at the time and they said yeah
that's that's what they were the
advisors
so that is canon that movie is canon
all right in in elvis lore
and it's it's one of the best elvis
movies because it's just [ __ ]
hilarious
the dude that plays elvis doesn't look
like him but he does he does that's the
one with michael shannon yeah michael he
doesn't look like but he does a great
job as that he's spiritually he becomes
channeling his channel's elvis his kind
of energy
and uh evidently that was as [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy as elvis was uh you know
elvis is always kind of like portrayed
as being kind of serious or something in
a way
like he's stuff here elvis was funny
elvis was on a lot of drugs too [ __ ]
at that period of his life although he
didn't consider him drugs because a
doctor prescribed him to him yeah he got
caught it doesn't count then yeah it
doesn't count
he got caught up in the same [ __ ] as
prince and
and [ __ ] michael jackson where
you got these quack doctors that give
you drugs that and
and [ __ ]
you're convincing yourself that you're
sick
you know
oh you're not taking my medicine you
know
but i got elvis figured out
i know what happened to him
he hurt his leg
when he was a little bit older and they
put him on some painkillers
and that's testosterone suppressive
and then he hit andrenopause or male
menopause and he started to feel like
[ __ ]
and he could
the symptoms he was describing
he says i don't feel right in my joints
and this and that but i just don't he's
talking about low testosterone
instead of just bumping him up with some
[ __ ] tests or [ __ ] giving him some
[ __ ] anabolics to [ __ ]
pump him back up
they gave him more [ __ ] painkillers
which makes it even worse
so
low t i kind of feel like that happened
a lot like but i didn't know what they
were doing but well i feel like that
happens well even nowadays like to a
lesser extent because people are like
know more about what's going on but but
the android a lot of people that were in
accidents or something like that and
they're like they have to have
painkillers for a while so they're not
like screaming and pain the whole time
but sometimes they get addicted to them
and the doctors just like keep
prescribing them and then like you kind
of like fall into this [ __ ] downward
spiral a young man can take painkillers
and then come off of them and recover
hormonally
because
a young man produces a lot of
testosterone
but a guy who's middle aged
can never really come off of
painkillers
and still feel right
because painkillers suppresses your
endocrine system so you'll be low t
a good endocrinologist a good doctor
will say okay now he's coming off that
let's go ahead and [ __ ] put him on
hrt and get his [ __ ] testosterone
levels back up
and he'll feel a lot better he'll be
able to heal up and it will keep some
[ __ ] fat off of him and he'll have
the energy he needs to [ __ ] work out
and [ __ ] continue his show
poor elvis man all he needed was hrt
put him on hrt elvis would have gone on
to his [ __ ] 70s
need to [ __ ] he didn't [ __ ] beat
mick jagger
i don't know what's keeping mick jagger
[ __ ] active
that motherfucker's a damn vampire
he just runs on heroin i guess i don't
[ __ ] know
i don't think somebody said that [ __ ]
is still alive so it's like you can't
like [ __ ] fault him for that right
he doesn't have an endocrine system
because he hasn't gained any weight last
time i saw him he was still skinny as
[ __ ]
well he's still the same [ __ ] is like
iggy pop and all right they're like old
as [ __ ] and they've done all like all
the drugs yeah and he's got like and
they're still skinny 22 year old
girlfriend old and 30 children and she's
still alive and i don't understand it
man [ __ ] a god
yeah it happens yeah so you know but uh
you can't well everybody's different
yeah you know what i'm saying you can't
just like prescribe genetics the same
[ __ ] for yeah some people just have like
kick-ass genetics i guess yeah i would
have taken elvis uh elvis had good
genetics for [ __ ] um
masculine beauty and voice and singing
and his intelligence was good i just
would have kept that [ __ ] bumped up on
that testosterone
and something like
winstrol and deanna ball cycles of that
and i could have kept
elvis would still be alive today and
probably still be doing good well i
don't know about that he'd probably be
dead by now wouldn't he no he was
younger than he was old
he was younger now he's the same age as
mick jagger yeah i guess why did he die
in 1977 right yeah but he was still
young
i think he just turned 40 wasn't he
no i thought he was older than that
wasn't he no 40-something he was young
1977. i think he was at 40. i can't
remember i thought he was older than
that
dropping a section i think i drop it in
the comments section i mean i remember
he died i think he was like 41 but i
can't tell how old he was he wasn't old
he wasn't old he was a young man
um
but you know from from his description
of his symptoms
the low test low testosterone
he hit andrenopods and didn't know what
it was women could hit him can hit
[ __ ] um menopause and and men hit
andrenopods
and camp guy says brings up uh frost
nixon which yeah if you haven't seen
that that's also really good um i saw
that in the theater i don't think you've
seen it but yeah it was really good
um
mr 88 is that elvis was very scared of
the beatles went about it rather weasley
yeah he did seem to be very bothered
bye might have been to play hate uh
because i feel like the beatles that was
kind of like the new thing that was
coming in
and they kind of addressed that a little
bit in uh elvis and nixon where
the beatles were coming in like the
british invasion was happening like this
is like the new thing and elvis kind of
i kind of feel like he felt like oh well
i'm like the old guard or i'm yeah so he
was kind of like trying to oh these
hippies and they're coming in and all
these drugs and everything like that but
the thing about it was that he was on
drugs too but he didn't really see it
like that
you know
he thought
he thought psychedelics were drugs
anything else was medication right
that's what i'm saying it's like even
though there's really not that much
difference yeah his thinking wasn't like
that he was a [ __ ] old-school thinker
um he uh elvis had not caught up
to how how rock evolved
um
he saw stuff like the beatles and
rolling stones to him that was like a
foreign invasion from england and that
was acid rock that was like drug music
yeah you know and then it wasn't any
good
elvis started to go more towards his
roots which was southern gospel gospel
yeah because he came up singing for
black churches all right in the southern
baptist tradition so he started to go
actually more black his sound was more
black but it was a retro black
not
the new coming black sound which was
more like james brown
well no you know that was already the
past um
like it was he was friends with james
brown james like funk and then it
started going into like disco it would
eventually
more like a disco kind of sound like
later there's a lot of misconceptions
about who elvis was and what his
relationship with black people was
elvis loved black people he came up
around black people he was a southern
share cropper who lived right next door
to them and was big friends with uh uh
james brown
he had james brown was over at graceland
several times and when [ __ ] elvis
died [ __ ] james brown [ __ ] lost it
he couldn't believe that he died
um
and [ __ ] elvis loved james brown
a lot yes people there there's a
the whole thing about elvis being a
racist that came from [ __ ] chuck d
and [ __ ] um and and um
public enemy which i'm a huge public
enemy fan i i really like public academy
but they but chuck d came out and says
no i just made that i just made that
lyric up
elvis was was it racist
he would they were [ __ ]
attacking him because he wasn't racist
near the segregational south you know i
don't think this he was acting like he
was black
yeah well i don't think it was that i
think like in hindsight it was easy to
say well
he took all of this quote unquote black
music
and
made it palatable for white people and i
can see how there could be like a lot of
resentment there so i get that i get
that
i don't elvis himself was not racist no
it was the same thing as eminem did
he you know eminem took black music and
he goes oh yeah and he put his own spin
on it and white people started listening
to it
but i know a lot of black dudes [ __ ]
back through the days that [ __ ]
actually [ __ ] were just huge in into
into eminem they they was i was like you
think eminem is the best rapper because
yeah eminem is the best one
it just depends
you know well music is art
it just depends on your taste it's all
subjective it's all subjective
so um elvis was kind of like eminem in
that in that way well i mean it's kind
of like i mean this is sort of analogous
like probably not as politically charged
but
i don't like
marilyn manson yeah uh for the fact that
he took got music off music or it was
more like goth industrial right yeah and
main streamed it so i'm like oh goody
now a bunch of like shows listen to this
that's a good analogy so it's kind of
like the same kind of thing right and i
and you know so i get it i feel resented
like i still can't
and i i you know agree that marilyn
manson made some okay [ __ ] i've never
like bought any of his stuff yeah but
i'm always gonna be mad because it's
like you took some [ __ ] that was good
and like now a bunch of [ __ ] listen
to it and i can't like like anymore
here's another angle people need to look
at being
being from a from a southern
family in mississippi
um all right i got people okay good
when you when you look at
when you look at elvis
singing very early rock and roll in the
50s
you had people saying well that's black
music
well not really
it was also just southern
music it was mississippi delta music
because of the in the mississippi delta
you had
blues
like howlin wolf and muddy waters
and the early mississippi delta blues
players
and that's what elvis was being
that's what his main influence was
so it wasn't uh
yeah
it had a racial
aspect
or an ethnic aspect
to that sound
but it was also regional it was just
the region in which elvis was growing up
in
and he's hearing that and he's learning
from those guys
and he starts to adopt that sound
because that's that was the regional
sound and that's what he liked
now everybody will tell you
from that era
the black artists from elvis's era
say will tell you that what elvis really
had was the look
okay
he had a
supermarketable look he was very
handsome
and he was the right age
and it was the right place at the right
time and the right [ __ ] technology
you could go to a little place and have
a single cut on an album and you could
have that played at a local radio
station and then everybody would hear it
so there was an element of luck to elvis
okay
and that's just the way it was
but that's okay because all the
history's like that all of history is
like that it's the right man the right
place the right time
okay
well you hear a lot too like sometimes
this happened in hindsight like some
[ __ ] comes out like for you know
not i'm not talking about elvis
specifically but somebody like that like
comes out and he has the right look to
write sound and it just happens to
happen at the right time and he gets
like super popular right but then like
later on you find out there's some other
poor [ __ ] that was doing the
exact same thing
um but he wasn't quite as good looking
or he didn't have quite as good
management there's something like that
out there right right what you know
exactly who you're talking about [ __ ]
uh jerry lee lewis
in some ways might have been better than
elvis but he didn't quite have the look
and he was bad
i mean in his day he was a bad dude yeah
i mean he was a cousin
i mean he married her but there you go
she was 13. yeah yeah he was just and he
i like his ass
but he said he was the devil
he was a while he was a pedophile yeah
well he didn't have the pedophile
understanding i know but it's still not
he was still not acceptable yeah even
back then yeah jerry lee lewis was the
[ __ ] devil yeah of his time his
music's awesome though yeah but yeah and
then he didn't seem like that and
another thing is you know along his line
as subversive as he was would have been
a little richer
and yeah you look at little rich little
richard was [ __ ] good man really good
yeah
and it was obvious that little richard
was gay
yeah
all right well yeah i mean it was
obvious nowadays no it was obvious i
mean it was obvious back then
to
to people of the time they knew but they
couldn't really
you couldn't accuse it because
they could closet [ __ ] and size step
there wasn't proof but evidently
everybody knew he was also the devil
from their point of view but he was good
little richard was [ __ ] really good
you know
yeah he was real good yeah actually
and he lived for a long time i'm into
all that he's still alive or he died oh
i'm pretty sure he died but yeah yeah
yeah i like him i mean i like elvis too
but i like a lot of that like 50s yeah
rockabilly it was just another time but
little richard had [ __ ] huge balls
huge balls
for his day
because
he was out
for him
as out as you could be as out as you
could be for his time
yeah
hell yeah
to be out and black yeah in that era
yeah and just be what you were like yeah
uh
yeah yeah no people just didn't really
do that back then
but it's my understanding for a good
reason it's my understanding from
experts of that [ __ ] time in that era
that they knew back then
it's just that uh that was as out as you
could be
and they were kind of it was a different
time they didn't make
direct
accusations everything was kind of
sideways accusations you know and and
little richard was a southern
personality
too so that it's another layer that you
fold in
but he was he was a genius
it's almost kind of like everybody
because i would kind of remember this
era yeah you would see people on tv like
little richard or paul lind or somebody
like that that obviously we're getting
obvious
i mean obvious flamingos flaming they
were the masters of it land [ __ ]
right that's what i mean but back then
it's like nobody it was almost like and
riptorn yeah so it's almost like
impolite to say how loud like everybody
knew it was everybody knew but it was
impolite i mean i don't know how much
like middle america like they were just
getting
yeah but it's just kind of like
everybody knew but it's like no one like
talked about it like almost like it
wasn't you weren't supposed to talk
about it
if they were famous and they were funny
yeah
then oh they could just be like that i
don't know it was really weird it's like
really weird for me as a boy growing up
i'm going to give the i'm going to give
the [ __ ] i'm going to give the award
best gay best in gay was paul land
bested gay destin gay was [ __ ] he was
such a [ __ ] and i love [ __ ] was
he was intelligent sharp wit sharp wit i
loved following [ __ ] funny as [ __ ] he
dominated the hollywood squares in that
show i mean they gave him the center
square all the time for a reason well
you watched that he was the best you
watched it just for him for pauline
because he was the funniest yeah he was
the point exactly
he just like man it's just like the [ __ ]
that he would come up with was just like
so [ __ ] funny he was just like very
very you can see all that on youtube
that's out there yeah he's hilarious
hilarious
uh mr88 says yeah carl perkins too yep
that too many of elvis's hits were
written by and previously recorded by
carl perkins yep that's right
it's just uh one of those things
and then mr idiot says chuck berry beat
them all that's the thing it's just kind
of like
you know i did everybody knows carl
perkins nowadays everybody knows chuck
berry but the thing about elvis
is that
yeah he didn't write most of his own
songs did he write any of his own songs
i kind of feel like he mostly just did
traditional songs or he did uh songs
that have previously been uh written by
other people but
there was just something about him he
had like the the charisma the looks blah
blah blah like i said a lot of it has to
do with the way you look then if you're
at the right place at the right time it
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with like how talented you are
necessarily which is kind of sad i mean
it does help
obviously but um
you know
it's not everything unfortunately
uh tammy says jerry lee lewis is still
alive holy [ __ ] is he really
86 little richard died 2020. yeah i
thought i remembered hearing that he had
died like kind of recently
i mean
karen lee says my grandma got hitched at
15 back in the 1930s so that was how it
was
yeah i people did marry younger i still
you know because i guess it's not like
women were like gonna go to college or
have a career or anything like that um
back in those days so i don't remember
what age my grandmother was
um she was 18 or 19. but her husband my
grandfather was 10 years older
and
i don't really recall anyone saying that
that was unusual she wasn't super young
but
um
karen lee said my grandma got hitched at
15 back in the 1930s oh 30s has nothing
15. like i said i'm pretty sure my
grandma she was old i think she was 19
or 20. but my grandfather was 10 years
older than her but like i said that
wasn't she didn't get married like as a
teenager but you just did that because
like i said it wasn't like women were
back in the 20s and 30s it's not like
they were necessarily going to go to
college or have a career or anything
like that so it's just kind of like you
married as young as possible yeah sly
go on go and [ __ ] stream go order
that [ __ ]
elvis and nixon
you'll love it i got it on blu-ray it's
one of my favorite movies
it's good it's good
i love michael shannon in everything and
him playing elvis although can we and
it's a true story it's true yeah it's
true i mean they do it like funny but
the whole situation was funny yeah so i
don't think they added too much on it
but so there's a story about elvis
trying to talk his way into the white
house
and to put himself on equal footing with
the president
because the president was the president
but elvis was a king
okay and [ __ ] it's just [ __ ] like
i said i just it's hilarious
in the office so he's like putting his
feet on his coffee table and eating his
eminence and he shows up with guns yeah
to see the press nixon is just kind of
like oh well
[Laughter]
yeah because it doesn't even occur to
elvis that he's just kind of like i
shouldn't do these things yeah not just
like what she shows up to be the
president he's [ __ ] carrying
concealed 1911's
yeah and all his boys are all carrying
guns and he brought nixon some guns yeah
and he gave knicks to the [ __ ]
like they were all like pearl handle or
whatever yeah well he knew about nixon's
military service so he gave him a
commemorative model you got to see it
man it's [ __ ] it's good it's good it
is very funny and then largely
ate up all of nix's m m's
not gonna lie i probably didn't
don't leave [ __ ] m m's in front of me
i'm gonna eat everywhere
well if they're plain probably not but
if they're peanut their peanut i think
if they're peanut then yeah i'm gonna
eat all them i'm sorry yeah just telling
you right now
uh mr 88 says one of my favorite quotes
uh john lennon talking about uh rock and
roll they would have called it chuck
berry but that name was already taken
that is a good quote actually i don't
think i've heard that one before
uh let me see
a good movie with matt damon behind the
candelabra about liberace
michael douglas plays liberace matt
damon plays his lover oh i get to see
that one man that sounds good i haven't
seen that man liberace was on tv all the
time when i was a kid
funny thing about liberace is one of his
biggest famous fans
was [ __ ] um
uh [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] i think the first time i saw him
was on the muppet show wasn't he on the
muppet show evil knievel
oh okay evil knievel
evil knievel was one of liberace's
biggest fans
i [ __ ] seen interviews with evil
knievel saying that he
went to vegas to see liberace
and thought that liberace was the
[ __ ] best performer he had ever seen
and was just
so brave you know he's stunning and
brave i guess you but he is what he said
and uh that he wanted his show
to be like liberace's show
now he was also an elvis fan okay i can
see that yeah he yeah
well he was all about like the glamour
glamour he liked glamour [ __ ] um
he had he wore elvis type motors clothes
with his motorcycle outfits he liked
elvis and he liked liberace
which is kind of funny when you think of
evil knievel because that [ __ ]
was like
super macho
hitting people with baseball bats and
trying to fight he was [ __ ] crazy
even knives was [ __ ] crazy well yeah
you have to be crazy to do what he was
doing
but
but he loved liberace he thought
liberation was interesting though
because i kind of feel like dudes like
that yeah you wouldn't think that they
would be because
i don't know like from a modern
perspective i think people would look
back at it and be like oh well evil
knievel he was all like this macho like
you know more of what we would consider
like a more conservative or like a jock
type of dude
um
redneck like a redneck type of dude very
aggressive but he was real into
liberace liberace and like elven like
you know yeah like i said you do the
[ __ ] uh outfits with all the
rhinestones and [ __ ] like that which
looking back on it now it's like that's
pretty gay oh yeah that's pretty gay oh
and i have and it's funny that they
wouldn't have perceived it like that
back then but that's absolutely what it
was i actually think he did maybe i
think he did maybe no i think evil king
evil knew exactly what that was
i think it was kind of a situation where
uh knievel was um
he was in
the very macho extremes of entertainment
you know what i mean
and liberace was in another extreme of
in of entertainment it was like the
pretty guy
yeah you know what i mean
so it was what he didn't have
yeah okay i can see that so it was kind
of he was admiring something that he
couldn't be because i think is what it
was but that's kind of cool that he
wasn't like no he liked that
that he wasn't like secretive about it
no because i feel like normally
especially back then like that type of
dude if they like liberace they would
keep that [ __ ] on the d yeah they would
they wanted they would like i don't want
anybody to see that i don't like that if
you shut up you like liberace
no he loved it that's okay yeah it would
be like that but it might have been a
release from his responsibility of
having to do these [ __ ] deadly stunts
that could have killed him too it's like
the other side yeah
like i see that's healthy i don't need
to have that i could be suspended from
the ceiling and flying around you know
like a butterfly and playing the piano
and having all these women love me you
know what i mean for playing this piano
because here's something else a lot of
people don't know liberace's fans were
all women
well yeah
you know
and
liberace wouldn't let it out that he was
gay because he thought that it would
turn all his female fans off
what are you talking about like women
would be probably be like okay i think
they knew back then i think liberace
didn't didn't know that i think back
then like they didn't understand like
the appeal like women love gay dudes
what do you talk about yeah i don't
think lebron she knew that
yeah i don't think he knew i feel like
everybody knows that now but like maybe
not like maybe back that they didn't
know that i think he misunderstood it as
sexual attraction
that's not that's not exactly what it is
no it kind of is but i don't know it's
if you're not a woman it's kind of like
hard to explain it's not exactly like
sexual attraction but
well liberace came out and said he
didn't want any of his female fans to
know that he was gay because he didn't
want to break anybody's hearts
oh that's but i don't think that's what
but i don't think he had to worry about
that because i think they all knew yeah
you know that's why they liked him
probably yeah that's probably why in in
in the in in in the ideology of the day
he didn't know that
people were unsophisticated in those
days even gay people were kind of
unsophisticated things well everyone was
on youtube yeah they didn't they didn't
know how
straight women thought you know straight
women were identifying with him and
thought that he was great
you know so
but he didn't see it that way he thought
he thought it was heterosexual
attraction it's not though it's not it's
not really the same it's kind of like
i think the reason that a lot of men i'm
not saying all women obviously because i
would never speak for everybody i'm just
me but i'm just saying that a lot of
women like
gay porn or you know
you know gay identified performers or
something like that not necessarily
because it's a sexual attraction it kind
of is but it's not exactly that it's
more like
it's a man
but they're more identifiable to you
like they seem more compassionate they
seem more they seem to have more
qualities that are more attractive to
you
than maybe a heterosexual man would have
maybe like i kind of feel like that's at
least that's where i'm coming at it from
i think that's what it was back then
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah that's
not probably not true for everybody but
i'm just saying like for me
that's kind of like where it comes from
it's like oh it's a dude but without all
the worst qualities of a dude you know
liberace listen to this
liberace's main fans at the time at the
time that we're talking about were
middle-aged women
okay
a lot of them divorced
and they yeah you know and that's who
and they're kind of like that
[ __ ] that i divorced yeah yeah
here's a guy and it's a man but he's
still kind of he's like one of us he's
singing to me yeah yeah yeah and he
seems like a nice man he's thinking
about love and he's anything yeah like
ladies love that [ __ ] and and it's not
always it's funny that a macho
[ __ ] like if go go back okay
they did a lot of [ __ ] shows on evil
knievel before he died on the history
channel and stuff
there's like two or three
interview uh [ __ ]
documentaries on him
evil was
he was kind he was an [ __ ] i mean i i
appreciate his ass he was kind of he was
an [ __ ] yeah he was uh but he was all
man okay i mean and the dude was [ __ ]
gambling with his life yeah i mean he
did do all that
i mean he was still a douche but it's
like you know he didn't do all that [ __ ]
yeah he did do all that [ __ ] he was a
modern day gladiator he was [ __ ]
doing these motorcycle stunts
with no [ __ ] body armor and busting
himself up he broke every [ __ ] bone
in his body all right for our
entertainment and he's doing it on a
harley davidson on a harley sportster
which is a motorcycle that is not
designed to be in the air and it doesn't
have a good suspension and [ __ ] it is
it is a a common street bike that's all
it is and he's doing these
amazing jumps on
and wiping out
and getting himself [ __ ] put in the
hospital for [ __ ] months all right
there wasn't any trick you know it
wasn't that david blaine [ __ ] to
that you know even though i like david
blaine there's david blaine's [ __ ]
good performer but i meant you know uh
who is that [ __ ] who's who was
constantly doing the stunts but he was
in this
it's it's obviously fake
what was that fucker's name i don't know
who you're talking about oh man
back in back in the [ __ ] late 90s
uh anyway
it was it was real stunts it wasn't
it wasn't [ __ ] trick photography and
he was getting busted up pretty bad
sly probably remembers in [ __ ] when i
was a kid
we had evel knievel toys
we were waiting for the next [ __ ]
stunt that he would do yeah my brother
we were getting built up to the snake
canyon jump i was about five or six or
seven waiting for the snake canyon jump
and we were talking we were talking [ __ ]
about oh yeah he's going to make it he's
going to make it now he didn't make it
all right
but it was just it was just uh something
of its time yeah i mean
it was another time
it was the internet of its day
because it was live action you're
waiting for that [ __ ] to be played on
abc
zach says you should google the
interiors of liberace's homes his taste
and design was horrifying it was yeah i
mean it was super tacky tacky but in a
way it's like so tacky that it's almost
kind of awesome
it was the disco era yeah and those i
don't know i kind of like some of this
stuff about it i'm not gonna lie they
had money and they did a lot of lsd
so you know zach said also i keep trying
to get my roommate to come to the gay
bar i go to so he can beat a woman hello
[Laughter]
okay yeah all the good women are at the
gay bars well yeah because you don't get
hit on yeah um it's much nicer it's much
nicer you just go to [ __ ] it's much
nicer being able to just go to a place
and drink and dance without like [ __ ]
dudes like breathing down your cleavage
and stuff every five minutes it's it's
nice one of the best events that me and
jenny used to go to was at a [ __ ] gay
bar but it's gay as [ __ ] [ __ ]
southern nights it's still in florida
still there
um you would love it there you would you
would love it zach southern knights is a
nice place nice nice but it has it has a
theater in it
it has a like seven or eight bars
yeah it looks like nothing like when you
drive past it it's just like in this
nowhere part of town
like it's across the street from like a
strip mall that has like some insurance
offices and [ __ ] just google southern
knights orlando it just looks like a
dump but when you go in it's [ __ ]
beautiful it's really beautiful in there
and it's like really big yeah it's all
this [ __ ] tv style stuff like
something from the jungle and y'all
you're just waiting the only thing
missing are like jacuzzis i mean we
haven't been there
so i hope it's still there but they had
uh
[ __ ] goth nights there they've had it
was a fetish night fetish nights the
porn stars would show up there [ __ ]
they had all kinds of [ __ ]
good bartenders you'd love southern
nights
camp guys said what if i watched gay
porn and got a boner that's why i'm
afraid to watch it
don't be afraid let your freak flag fly
that's [ __ ] who said that yeah i'd be
a good camp guy yeah cam guy you gay
[ __ ]
that's okay it doesn't mean it's all on
the spectrum don't worry about it uh
karen lee said yes jenny you got it when
i was talking about
why women like gay men i guess so yeah
mr adam said i'm male but i assumed
women felt comfortable around gay men
because there were no sexual undertones
or baggage they could just be a person
without dodging being hit on
no it's not that i think they do it's
not that well how would you're a man how
would you know i've just watched that
[ __ ] happen how would you i've watched
that [ __ ] happening i'm just saying that
that's that might be part of it because
like i said that's why a lot of women
will go to gay bars
because they just want to like go dance
and drink without being hit on by creeps
like you know you do have some of that
there is
oh he's
shut this [ __ ] down this is how you
because [ __ ] one of my best club
buddies [ __ ] toby is a [ __ ]
leather daddy all right and me and toby
are [ __ ] we'll be running it all
[ __ ] night all right and toby once he
gets drunk he he's he turns lesbian and
he starts [ __ ] with the women all
right
and he'll get all up on jenny
and jenny will start [ __ ] making out
with him and stuff and i gotta step in
and go hold on toby hold on it's just
going too far and then he'll try to suck
me into the [ __ ] okay well yeah he'll
try to suck but i've known toby a long
time yeah like [ __ ] random yeah but
no women like gay dudes and [ __ ]
toby's toby's a [ __ ] good looking
dude all right he's he's yeah he's about
my age well if you're trying to be
honest
if you
didn't he's another daddy if you didn't
know him yeah you would know he was you
wouldn't assume that he was gay no he
doesn't look gay you very like people
don't look gay but you know what i mean
he doesn't look like what you would it's
not stereotypically gay you got to watch
it though man [ __ ] toby you [ __ ]
try to grab a [ __ ] and the next
thing that he he's always trying to be
superior you're talking about
and you know i'm like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
you [ __ ] stop that [ __ ] and he's like
well hey
he wants to do that and then he'll try
to get on jenny but we've known him for
[ __ ] what almost 20 years i mean it's
well yeah it's been a long time maybe
like more like 50 yeah zach you would
love [ __ ] toby but toby would think
you were too much of a [ __ ] boy he's
like you're not masculine i mean he's
older than we are
by a couple years he's older than me
about it he's in his 50s
he's a uh he's he's in the uh
he's in the medical profession he's a
head nurse yeah he's a head nurse yeah
yeah so you're not talking about a dummy
you got money
too trying to get that [ __ ] to go on
[ __ ] hrt my other [ __ ] friend the
bouncer at the club is like we gotta
this [ __ ] gotta be on hrt because he
shows up and he's sucking
leather daddy kind of revealing outfits
he's losing weight he's getting skinny
he's getting skinny he needs to [ __ ]
puff up
and he's like yeah no i need to go on
i don't know if he looks good the way he
is i don't maybe he looks good but he
yeah i know how he wants to look you
know what i mean he tells me i i know
how he wants to look
but uh no i think it's funny you know
and and one of the reasons why you know
me
me and him fell in
is i didn't know he was gay he was just
a dude you know like we were hanging out
i don't know honestly that did not occur
to me when i first met you yeah i didn't
give a [ __ ] which is funny well because
like you're in the gas scene yeah i and
it's just kind of like i see dudes
dressed like that i don't it i don't
jump again i just like jump to like oh
he's a goth dude it doesn't like yeah
his sexuality doesn't occur to me right
so when he said he was gay later on i
was like oh okay like that yeah it
hadn't occurred to me and he um
he
likes macho dudes and [ __ ] he's got
respect for [ __ ] guys you know he
likes real men and he's he tells me it's
kind of hard because i like real men but
if i have sex with them then they're not
real men anymore from my point of view i
like straight guys that's what he likes
all right
so you gotta [ __ ] watch it with him
even though he does have boyfriends it's
just that
yeah he had one for a while yeah he he
never thinks his people i liked actually
yeah he was good dude he was good dude
and [ __ ] uh but he never thinks dudes
measure i understand that that i
understand
the conundrum that he's in very big i
understand the conundrum as soon as he
has sex with the dude
all of a sudden they're not a real dude
to him because he likes straight guys
so he took so it kind of he's in like
man he's in a pickle he's in a pickle a
little bit yeah
so
but i just told him says this is how it
is and this is how you gotta roll
because this is what they this is the
hand you were dealt i mean you just
gotta like [ __ ] take people as they
all right yeah
and i said well i i i even tried to
[ __ ] flip him straight i said you got
all these women that [ __ ] love you
why don't you just [ __ ] go out with
one of these girls because he's not into
this he's not in there no really there's
not really he's not really he wasn't
really into it he's not he wasn't into
it and that's just but he's just not
because that says look you got that one
right there that's calling you and then
you go down right there says why don't
you just get and he's like they're just
it's just not the same yeah he's just uh
he's just really not right he's just
really not yeah
but like i said that's why like i said
one i've known him forever two he's a
really good dancer yeah and a lot of
times like you'll just be over there
drinking or talking to somebody about
guns or something like that and it's
like i want to dance and you're not
dancing so if he's dancing i'm like well
i'm going to go dance with toby then
that's right because he's a good dancer
well yeah so you know
he does this thing i don't take it
seriously yeah i'm not
and he and he kind of like you enjoy
well and he um he's always like
he does like this whole like goddess
thing i was like okay i like this this
is nice
but you know what i mean i trust toby
just like i trust him like i trust the
girlfriends you know what i mean yeah
yeah you know i wouldn't like it's just
toby he's just like one of our
girlfriends he's awesome i'm gonna go to
the restaurant
even though but yeah it's it's like that
yeah i'm just kind of like well he's
here and he's a good dancer so he's a
really good dancer but like i said i
think that's why a lot of women like him
because
i'm sure this will shock no one but it's
like a lot of straight dudes
are really not that good a dancer you're
not a good dancer and
that is something if you're kind of in
the club scene
then that's something that people are
gonna notice
uh that's something that i notice if
you're if i'm standing there and like i
see some dude in like [ __ ] cargo
shorts and flip-flops or crocs or
whatever and you're out there dancing
and i'm using bunny rabbit ears as eddie
izzard says um
i i i question i was like how
how good can this dude be at other
things if that is how he dances because
man that is that is really not that's
really not good you know what i'm saying
um
but i don't know what it is it's like
a lot of dudes are just really not good
dancers like
i don't know
kind of like
normie white dudes
generally are really not good dancers
you don't really see it some goths are
good dancers now some goth dudes are not
good dancers now some goth women aren't
good dancers either
but
a lot of goth dudes i kind of feel like
they at least they try at least they go
for it
like they're like i can't dance but i'm
at least like you know i'm waving my
arms like they're doing something
they're
you know it's not good probably but you
know they're they're at least putting
themselves out there
white dudes will just kind of go out
there and just kind of like shuffle
around
you know what i mean and then they're
just kind of like in the way of people
that are actually trying to dance and
you're just kind of like should i just
like put my elbow in your kidney or what
you're just kind of like standing here
just
going from foot to foot and it's just
kind of like
i don't know that i don't know but um
yeah so i think the fact that
i think the fact that toby is
um
kind of like widely loved is one of the
things is one he's you know he's a good
looking dude and he dresses cool but
also he's a really good dancer
you know what i mean yeah because it
takes something to kind of like put
yourself out there and dance like in a
way that
is not just
because i was saying earlier like while
you were in the bathroom like a lot of
like normy white dudes will just sit out
there and like just shuffle around from
foot to foot yeah yeah like they're not
even committing to anything no they're
not even dancing i mean [ __ ]
there used to be a guy that used to go
to the castle who
he was basically look like he was doing
like [ __ ] karate moves yeah i
remember that guy which
which looked kind of ridiculous but i'm
like hey at least he's got a style yeah
and at least he's like putting himself
out there he's not just standing there
going doo doo doo yeah i'm just walking
elise is not doing that i'm gonna show
toby at lec's making a statement
you know what i'm saying i can respect
that i can respect that so i think
that's what it is i think that's what it
is i'm gonna shows toby
what's that finally strong 78 my top
three requirements for the ideal woman
have always been good with money can
cook and can hula dance
[Laughter]
there is a lot to be said for people
that can dance i'm just saying i'm just
saying
it's more important than than you
realize if you've got rhythm then that's
kind of a big thing
karen lee says i need a guy roommate
cook fix my hair and make up and clean
yeah that'd be nice wouldn't it
uh linwood slides asking you um
yeah i have a small gut what would i
need to do besides sit up to make it
just sit-ups to make it disappear
uh well i don't know how old you are i
think you're what close to 60 right yeah
you said he graduated from high school
in seventy did you go on hrt
hormone replacement therapy start
bumping testosterone
and uh
also other things like hcg
um you can research that
on your own do that and then once you
have
your hormonal
situation taken care of
doing things like sit-ups will [ __ ]
rapidly get rid of that which i'm in
that phase right now
i was doing upper body and chest for a
long time
now i'm doing [ __ ] um
uh
what do you call it
uh
midriff
oh [ __ ] this is not a good picture i was
trying to get a picture because they're
some all right can you see that they
can't see that [ __ ]
bundy data says john travolta can dance
yeah that's true
what was that saying i'm just saying um
john travolta wasn't bad looking when he
was younger
too bad he's a scientologist yeah kind
of like makes him significantly less
foxy
but you know what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do he can't dance
though i'll give him that he can kind of
sing too
so
i'm a big fan of grease what can i say
oh uh oh we got
sex bots sex spots attack of the sex
bots yeah somebody do we even have any
moderator in here you might have to get
rid of them yeah moderators might have
to jump in there i think we might have
some moderators in there zach is i think
the only moderator in here
zach and tammy are moderators
i can't do [ __ ] from this [ __ ] yeah i
think they're the only moderators in
here
so we're just gonna be
oh boy naked hd fun best adult dating
site oh boy i'm gonna hop right over to
that because we've been along we've been
online for two months
they start like invading well it's not
just that because every time i put every
time i upload a video and like post a
video like
almost inevitably like the first comment
is a sex bot
like a thing like that i have to go in
and like
get rid of it do you want to go and get
rid of it i'm going to show you guys a
[ __ ] cute picture jenny
oh that's me yeah i thought you were
looking for i thought you really yeah i
was looking for it remember when we took
those pictures of you yeah
yeah
our friend tony took that picture
i remember we went over to his apartment
and we took like a whole bunch of
pictures
took one and he had one with a guitar
and he had all the other stuff going on
all kind of god
i'm looking for
i found one picture of him but it's like
washed out
i don't know what to tell you i can't
see
it washed out ass [ __ ] pictures
washed out as [ __ ] pictures yeah
there's lots of good pictures of my
phone okay
i'm gonna have to go back to that one
mr88 said the first song on mr bungle's
first album was titled travolta
he threatened to sue if they didn't pull
the name
so they renamed it quota quote
the scientologist man they will sue the
pants right off you
tammy said just got back in with the
puppy and hear sex pots yeah we've got
sex box showing up good get rid of the
sex spots for us
how's the puppy
the puppy got bit by a bee
speaking of which
well not puppies orbeez but you know
what i mean little fur babies where is
pokey
she came in at the beginning of the show
and like rubbed against my leg like hey
mama and then she like took off i don't
know where she went yeah
that is actually the guess the only
picture we have
let me see uh okay yeah that's toby
there with the [ __ ] x on his chest
that's me and jenny on the other side
i'm safe i can get
it's not too it's not bad
that's toby yeah he looks very tall yeah
he's up on a step yeah i think he was
standing on something yeah that was like
he's tall but he's not that type that
was me when i had hair there on the
other side
and that's me and jen and that's aurora
and her ex-husband and jacob and jacob
jacob went back to um colombia
they got divorced
he was colombian guy he's famous in
colombia for doing a bunch of [ __ ]
vampire type stuff he'd be on television
and everything
karen said i don't look at my picks when
i was 19 as i'm 63 and age is not kind
it indeed is not
tammy's i asked about the puppy he's
okay playing with his toys right now
okay well that's good i was kind of
worried when you said that he got like
stung by a bee
how long have we been streaming
three hours and thirty-four okay it's
probably about time to shut it down then
yeah cause zach just said um i love how
this is inadvertently turned into a
sidetrack show yeah well yeah it did
well because you know we we covered the
topic and so tom was like oh goody now i
can like talk about random [ __ ] yeah
okay so uh my advice was uh watch elvis
versus nixon uh what else was the other
movie that we recommended um
i guess that was about it
and we're gonna see the new elvis movie
and we're going to see top gun
among other things yeah we'll see
something tomorrow sound good
yeah okay yeah oh and keep in mind to
you the side track show this week yeah
is going to be on saturday night instead
of friday night because friday night
yeah we are going to will's pub yeah
because she's she's just jean loves
jezebel and rose garden
funeral party yeah so we're not gonna be
home right friday night so we're gonna
do the sidetrack shows and saturday
night thank you for the super chats we
haven't had super chats in [ __ ] weeks
we probably made 30 bucks but hey
that's how it is [ __ ]
i know what the hell's going on i mean
the whole economy is like [ __ ] nobody
knows what's going to happen all right
so this is an escapist style show
do what you can to cover your own ass
oh people are saying food shortages
might happen no but nobody knows do what
you can take care of yourself and thank
you for your [ __ ] money because we're
gonna try to take care of ourselves too
that's right yeah all right so we will
see you guys for the sidetrack show on
saturday night remember it's gonna be
saturday night not friday yeah uh and
thank you everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us this evening yeah uh
so we will see you guys on saturday
good night